GOOD MORNING WE ARE TRYING TO
CALL THE WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE COMMITTEE ORDER. IF THE
SERGEANTS WOULD CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS INCLUDING OUR AUTHORS
NOTED FOR MARIA HERE. BUT BEFORE
YOU BEGIN WILL COVER THE STEPS
WE'RE TAKING TO PRESERVE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE AND TO
IT SURE PUBLIC ACCESS OUR
CONVERSATION TO ENSURE MEMBERS
OF THE MEDIA AND PUBLIC HAVE
ACCESS TO THE PROCEEDINGS TODAY.
THE HEARING WILL BE STREAMED ON
THE ASSEMBLY'S WEBSITE AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC CAN
PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN PERSON HERE
IN ROOM FOUR FOUR FOUR. OR VIA
THE TELEPHONE. FOR ANY MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC PRESENT HEARING
HEARING ROOM WE ARE CONTINUING
TO REQUIRE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
AS YOU CAN SEE. PLEASE FOLLOW
THE DIRECTIONS OF THE SERGEANTS
AND THE POSTED GUIDANCE
THROUGHOUT THE ROUND. IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC WOULD LIKE
TO TEST TRYING TO BILL OR- WE
DON'T HAVE ANY FRESH ITEMS. I
ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE OF APPROPRIATE TIME.
A COPY OF THE AGENDA IS
AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE. FOR
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WE
WILL BE PROVIDING COMMENT VIA
THE TELEPHONE. READING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE IN
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THE
HEARING IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR FOUR
FOUR PLEASE CALL IN WHEN THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'D LIKE TO
COMMENT ON BEGIN THEIR
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU THE
INSTRUCTIONS OF HOW TO BE PLACED
IN THE QUEUE. IF YOU'RE CALLING
AND PLEASE REMEMBER TO ELIMINATE
ALL OF YOUR BACKGROUND NOISE.
INCLUDES MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST IN YOUR DEVICES TO
REDUCE. SOUND ISSUES. FINALLY I
WANT TO KNOWLEDGE OF THE
ASSEMBLY HAS EXPERIENCED A
NUMBER OF DISRUPTIONS TO
COMEDIAN FOR PROCEEDINGS IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS WE WILL ENSURE
THAT ALL VOICES ARE HEARD
HOWEVER CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDES.
THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THE
HEARING IS PROHIBITED I WANT TO
THANK YOU IN ADVANCE FOR YOUR
COOPERATION WITH THAT. WELL WE
GOT THROUGH THAT AND I STILL
DON'T SEE ANY OFF THIRTIES.
MAYBE MR BANNOCK.
MMHM.
YEAH YEAH. YEAH YEAH YEAH YOU
HAVE TO AND IT'S FUNNY WHEN I
REMEMBER. WE WILL BEGIN WITH
MISTER BENNETT'S BILL BECAUSE
HE'S HERE THANK YOU MISTER
BENNETT WITH AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
NINE AND WE'RE READY WHEN YOU.
IT WILL BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
WE DON'T YET HAVE A QUORUM BUT
WHEN WE DO. SURE WILL HAVE A
MUCH. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND- MEMBERS. I'D LIKE TO START
BY ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS IN
THE ANALYSIS AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF- OUTSTANDING
WORK ON THIS BILL IN PARTICULAR
IT. TO SOME NUMBER OF THINGS IN
THERE THAT WE REALLY APPRECIATE
IN TERMS OF THE MEMBERS OF THANK
YOU- AS MANY OF US EXPERIENCE
DURING THE PANDEMIC PARKS AND
TRAILS WERE USED EXTENSIVELY BY
THE PUBLIC. HOW THE POPULARITY
OF TRAIL SHOWS HOW MUCH OF A
GROWING DEMAND THERE IS OUT.
THERE FOR OUTSIDE ACTIVITIES AND
HOW MUCH STRESS TRAILS
EXPERIENCED OVER THE PAST TWO
YEARS. IN FACT ACCORDING TO
SURVEYS CONDUCTED BY THE OUTDOOR
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION. TRAIL USES
THE MOST POPULAR OUT THERE ARE
ACTIVITY IN THE NATION- IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN PROPOSITION
SIXTY EIGHT CONTAINED TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR.
NATURAL SURFACE TRAIL
INVESTMENTS TO THE TRAILS AND
GREENWAYS PROGRAM. TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION MAY SOUND LIKE A LOT OF
MONEY. BUT THE GRANT PROGRAM
RECEIVED OVER. FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. IN REQUESTED
MANY INVESTMENTS WENT UNMET.
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET CONTAINING
DIGITAL FUNDING SOURCE THROUGH
THE STATE. PROGRAM AND FUNDS OF
FACILITATE EXPANDED. ACCESS
AMONG THOSE LEAST ABLE TO
AFFORD- INDOOR EXPERIENCE OUR
NATURAL LANDSCAPES. DESPITE THE
INVESTMENTS THE BUDGET DID NOT
INCLUDE INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS IN OUR TRAILS.
SYSTEM FEDERAL FUNDS FOR THIS
TYPE OF EXPENDITURE. FALLS
WOEFULLY SHORT IN THE STATE. HAS
NO LONG TERM FUNDING SOURCE
EITHER. AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY NINE
ADDRESSES THIS NEED BY
ESTABLISHING A TRAILS AND
GREENWAYS PROGRAM THROUGH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY. AND
PROVIDES FUNDING THROUGH A GRANT
PROGRAM. HERE WITH ME TODAY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. IS DOUG HANSON
WEST RAILS TO TRAILS
CONSERVANCY. AND DEREK DAHLE
FLY- WITH THE LEAGUE OF CITIES.
THANK YOU GENTLEMEN FOR BEING
HERE. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
IT'S DARK. I PREFER THE CAL PARK
AND REC SINCE- C. PRS IS THE
FIVE THOUSAND STRONG TRADE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTATIVE UP
ALL THE LOCAL. PROFESSIONALS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND I
STARK MIGHT MY TESTIMONY BY
ASKING THE QUESTION WHAT WHAT
ARE PARKS WITHOUT TRAILS.
THEY'RE OPEN SPACE PRESERVES SO
YOU KNOW TRAILS ARE MOBILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE YOUR DESTINATION
LINKAGES PUBLIC ACCESS CORRIDORS
WITHIN OUR- FEDERAL STATE AND
LOCAL PARK SYSTEMS THAT PROVIDE
COUNTLESS PUBLIC HEALTH ECONOMIC
SOCIAL WELL BEING BENEFITS TO
THE STATE. AND TO DATE
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T HAVE A STATE
SPONSORED BY THE SOURCE FOR
THESE TYPES OF TRAILS- TO THE
POINT. THE PRICES REALLY
GRATEFUL TO THE ADMINISTRATION
LEGISLATURE FOR THE
APPROPRIATION OF A HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS LAST YEAR. FOR
THE STATEWIDE PARK PROGRAM THAT
ADDRESSED PARK PORT COMMUNITY
INVESTMENTS ARE ALSO VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WENT FOR OUTDOOR
PROGRAMMING OUTDOOR. RECREATION
PROGRAMMING IN THE STATE BUT
WE'D LIKE TO SEE SOME SORT OF
COMMENSURATE- DEDICATION TO
FUNDING FOR RECREATION TRAILS
WHEN CALIFORNIA PRIDE OR SELF
LOVE THE NATURE AND THE OUTDOORS
AND WE HAVE A BIG OUTDOOR ETHIC
BUT- AND WHAT BETTER WAY TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT. STAND THROUGH
INVESTMENTS IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ALLOWS US TO
TOUCH FEEL. AND SEE THE OUTDOORS
IN OUR NATURE. RESPECTFULLY. ASK
IN YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS. MORNING
TURN MEMBERS DECKED OFF HIM
HAPPILY CALIFORNIA CITIES WE'RE
PLEASED TO BE IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY NINE- THIS
MEASURE WILL PROVIDE CRITICAL ON
GOING FUNDING TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO CREATE EXPAND AND
IMPROVE TRAILS AND GREENWAYS-
CALIFORNIA TRAILS HAVE SEEN. AN
INCREASED RECREATIONAL USE
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC AND HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE. A VERY
POPULAR FORM OF OUTDOOR
ENGAGEMENT ACROSS THE STATE FOR
BOTH PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH-
I OF. MENTAL HEALTH- AND THE
INVESTMENTS IN AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY NINE WOULD ALLOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO ENSURE THAT THE
NATURAL SURFACE TRAILS CAN TO
CONTINUE TO BE SUPPORTED BY
RESIDENTS WE ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU CAN A MAN DO WE HAVE ANY
MORE SUPPORT HERE IN THE ROOM ON
THIS BILL. DOESN'T LOOK LIKE IT
SO WE WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
FOR ANY SUPPORT AT THIS MEASURE
AB SEVENTEEN NINETY NINE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS ONLINE JUST
WILL BE TAKING YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
OPERATOR THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY NINE. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY NINE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. ONE MOMENT WHILE WE GATHER THE
NUMBERS. THE FEDERAL. NINE
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
FOR THE PACIFIC CREST TRAIL
ASSOCIATION AND DEPARTMENT. I DO
. I DIDN'T HEAR THAT WATER THE
CIVIC TRAILS ASSOCIATION.
OPERATOR ANY LINES IN SUPPORT.
YES ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE
WE'RE GATHERING THE LINE NUMBERS. NINE TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ELAINE ORTIZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORD AND WE HAVE
THE SUPPORT IT'S AMENDED
PETITION BUT APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENT- SUGGESTED BY THE
CANADIAN RECORD WORKING YEAH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE WAY TO
HAVE THREE OTHERS THE CUTE.
WHICH IS.
YES THIS IS MICHAEL AND ALONG
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MOUNTAIN
BIKE COALITION AND WE ARE IN
SCHOOL. THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SON SCOTT BORROW-
ADVOCACY DIRECTOR OF BICYCLE
TRAILS COUNCIL THE EAST BAY ON
BEHALF OF BY ZERO TWELVE COUNCIL
EAST BAY WE SUPPORT AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY NINE. THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT WHILE WE GATHER THE
MY NUMBERS. MY THIRTY YOUR MIND
IS A PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE
THIRTY THREE YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO LINE
THIRTY LINE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS LAURA CALLING
WITH RAILS TO TRAILS CONSERVANCY
WE ARE CO SPONSOR AND SUPPORT
THE BILL THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS WARREN
WEALTH WITH THE MARIN COUNTY
BICYCLE COALITION AND SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND ONE MOMENT FOR OUR
LAUGH NINE NINE THIRTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO DEBBIE THANK THERE WITH
ABOUT BUT SHALL THE LAND BUT WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB. SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY NINE. THERE ARE NO MORE
BLINDS IN Q. PUTTING THE PORT OF
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY NINE THANK
YOU OPERATOR WE DO HAVE ONE
SUPPORTER HERE IN THE ROOM SO
WE'LL TAKE YOUR TESTIMONY NOW
YOU'RE HAVING A MILE AND A HALF
OF THE MID PENINSULA REGIONAL
OPEN SPACE DISTRICT AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION SUPPORT THE SPELL. AT
AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
ON RECORD BUT WE'LL SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION HERE IN THE
ROOM OR IN THE HALLWAY. AND IN
THE MEANTIME OPERATOR WILL WE
SEE IF THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION IN
THE QUEUE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AT THAT ZERO. I HAVE NO COMMENT
IN Q. IN OPPOSITION OF AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY NINE THANK GOD
WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION HERE IN
THE ROOM PART APPEARS IN THE
HALLWAY SO. WITH THAT I WILL
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEAMAN MISTER BENNETT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF MANAGER AND I
WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE THE-
REMARKABLE CONTRIBUTIONS OF MR
HOUSTON WHO'S THAT PERHAPS
LEADING TRAILS ADVOCATE- IN IN
THE STATE- IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE OF. LONG
TERM PERMANENT FUNDING FOR
TRAILS- AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER BENNETT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
DEDICATION HARD TRAILS IS
CRITICAL I THINK AS YOU SAID.
THOSE OF US- WITH KIDS DURING
THE PANDEMIC ESPECIALLY
UNDERSTOOD THE VALUE OF GETTING
THEM OUT AND MOVING THEIR BODIES
IN NATURE SO I APPRECIATE YOUR-
DEDICATION TO THAT AND IT DOES
ENJOY RECOGNITION AND WE DON'T
YET HAVE A QUORUM SO WE WILL.
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ONCE WE GET A
QUORUM BUT YOU THANK YOU
GENTLEMEN. THE SERRANO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO TAKE UP. REBELS WE WILL
MOVE ON. AB TWENTY ONE OH NINE
BY MISTER BENNETT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
TWENTY ONE OH NINE- WILL
PROHIBIT YOU SWIMBAIT OR ANIMAL
DECOYS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ATTRACTING OR VIEWING WHITE
SHARKS THE WARM WATERS OFF THE
COAST OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
HAVE ATTRACTED AN UNPRECEDENTED
NUMBER OF JUVENILE WHITE SHARKS
IN THEIR TERRITORY HAS MOVED
SIGNIFICANTLY NORTHWARD. AS THE
OCEANS WARM NATURALLY THE PUBLIC
IS INTERESTED IN SEEING THESE
INCREDIBLE CREATURES OFTEN UP
CLOSE AND SOME PEOPLE WHO RUN
WHITE SHARK VIEWING TOURS BY
BOAT HAVE REQUESTED TO USE
ATTRACTANTS FOR CAGE DIVING
OPERATIONS UNFORTUNATELY THESE
ARE OFTEN IN AREAS WITH AN
ABUNDANCE OF BOTH WHITE SHARKS
IN THE OCEAN USERS POTENTIALLY
PUTTING. A MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
AT RISK TO INCREASE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF SUCCESSFUL VIEWING
TOUR OPERATORS MAY ATTEMPT TO
USE SOME FORM OF ATTRACTED CHUM
BAIT DECOY CENTER TO BRING WHITE
SHARKS NEAR THE VESSEL USE OF
THESE ATTRACTANTS WHICH ARE
FEEDING CUES FOR WHITE SHARKS
MADE PRIESTS ARE INTERESTING
OTHER THINGS IN THE WATER. SUCH
AS SWIMMERS AND SURFERS IN THE
PAST FIFTY TWO YEARS THERE'VE.
ONLY BEEN TWO HUNDRED AND TWO
REPORTED SHARK HUMAN INCIDENTS.
AND I'VE JUST WHAT IS NOT AN
ATTEMPT TRIED TO INFLAME THE
PUBLIC ABOUT HOW TERRIBLE ARE
VERY SCARY SHARKS ARE IN THE
OCEAN- BUT- WE DON'T WANT TO
NUMBER- FLAT TO RISE IN TERMS OF
NUMBER OF INCIDENTS AND- WHILE
MANY PEOPLE- LOVE TO WATCH SHARK
WEEK AND WE DON'T WANT TO
COASTAL WATERS CALIFORNIA BECOME
JOBS. WITH THAT- I HAVE WITH ME
TODAY JENNIFER FEARING- TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU MISS HEARING IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND WE HAVE A QUORUM.
OR BEFORE YOU. THE FATHER OF.
VERIFICATION HI HERE. TO HERE
BENNETT. BIGELOW FREE. GARCIA
KALRA LEVY MERE THIRTY NORMAN
RUBIO SALAS SMITH THERE THE
APPROVED WHAT YOUR WARD. WE HAVE
A CURRENT THANK YOU THANK. GOOD
MORNING MANAGER MEMBERS JENNIFER
FEARING I'M PLEASED TESTIFIED
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FISHING GAME WARDENS
SUPERVISORS AND MANAGERS
ASSOCIATION THE MONTEREY BAY
AQUARIUM AND OSHANA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE OH
NINE. WHITE SHARKS ALSO CALLED
THE GREAT SHARKS ARE THE EARTH'S
LARGEST OCEAN PREDATORY FISH
THEY REMAIN HOWEVER THE ONE OF
THE LEAST UNDERSTOOD OCEAN
ANIMALS DESPITE THE ENORMOUS
PUBLIC AND SCIENTIFIC INTEREST
IN THEM WHITE SHARKS OFF
CALIFORNIA ARE PART OF A
GENETICALLY DISTINCT NORTHEAST
PACIFIC POPULATION SATELLITE
TAGGING STUDIES HAVE DOCUMENTED
THE SHARKS MIGRATING LONG
DISTANCES TO HAWAII MEXICO AND
THE FAMOUS WHITE SHARK CAFE
WHERE THEY CONGREGATE THOUSANDS
OF MILES FROM SHORE. AS TOP
PREDATORS WHITE SHARKS PLAY AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN KEEPING
CALIFORNIA'S OCEAN ECOSYSTEMS
HEALTHY HELPING CONTROL
POPULATIONS OF SEALS AND SEA
LIONS AND KEEPING FISH
POPULATIONS STRONG BY REMOVING
SECOND WEEK INDIVIDUALS
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD'S OCEANS
ECOLOGISTS HAVE FOUND THAT
HEALTHY SHARK POPULATIONS ARE AN
INDICATOR OF OVERALL ECOSYSTEM
HEALTH HEALTHY POPULATION OF
WHITE SHARKS INSURERS A MORE
RESILIENT OCEAN ECOSYSTEM IN THE
FACE OF CLIMATE CHANGE. WHITE
SHARKS ARE PROHIBITED SPECIES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT CANNOT BE
TARGETED OR KEPT IN FISHERIES
BUT THERE IS STILL SOME
INCIDENTAL CATCH RECENT
POPULATION ESTIMATES INDICATE
THAT THE POPULATION IS IN THE
PROCESS OF RECOVERING FROM
HISTORIC DEPLETION. WHITE SHARKS
ARE COMMONLY SEEN AT THE- OCEAN
SURFACE AND- WHITE SHARKS ARE
FREQUENTLY SEEN IN SHALLOW NEAR
SHORE WATERS OFF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS AN IMPORTANT
NURSERY AREA FOR YOUNG WHITE
SHARKS ESPECIALLY. IN THE SUMMER
AND DURING WARM WATER PERIODS
THEY ARE INCREASINGLY FOUND IN
MONTEREY BAY DUE TO WARMING
OCEAN WATERS CAUSED BY CLIMATE
CHANGE. AND THE CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA REGION FROM ON YOU IN
A WAY LOW POINT TO POINT REYES
OUT TO THE FAIRLAWN ISLANDS A
PRIME FEEDING GROUND FOR ADULT
GREAT WHITES. WITH INCREASED
SIGHTINGS COMES INCREASED
INTEREST AND THE PUBLIC HAS
BECOME MORE AWARE OF THEIR
PRESENCE FURTHER INCREASING THE
POTENTIAL FOR HUMAN SHARK
INTERACTIONS. AND AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STATED SOME
INDIVIDUALS RUNNING WHITE SHARK
VIEWING TOURS BY BOAT WANT TO
USE ATTRACTANTS FOR CAGE DIVING.
PLANS IN AREAS WITH AN ABUNDANCE
OF BOTH WHITE SHARKS AND OCEAN
USERS. PROHIBITING THIS PRACTICE
WILL PROTECT BOTH SHARKS AND THE
PUBLIC WHILE KEEPING THIS
IMPORTANT NATURAL OCEAN PREDATOR
WILD WE APPRECIATE YOU MISTER
BENNETT FOR CHAMPIONING THIS
EFFORT TO PROTECT WHITE SHARKS
PUBLIC SAFETY. AND TO IMPROVE
THE MANAGEMENT OF ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S REMARKABLE MARINE
RESOURCES WE ARE DRY THOSE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS HEARING. SEE
IF WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT HERE IN THE ROOM OR IF
THE SURGEONS WILL SEE IF
ANYONE'S OUT THE HALLWAY. M.
FINANCING WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES OPERATED ANYONE ON OF IN.
ON THE- THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND LADIES IN GENTLEMEN IF HE
WAS JUST CONSERVE OF AB TWENTY
ONE OH NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN HE WAS TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY ONE OH NINE. YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
NINE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR KIM
DELFINO ON BEHALF OF DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE OH NINE
WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION ON FILE TO
ANY OPPOSITION HERE IN THE ROOM.
OUTSIDE THE ROOM. SEEING NONE
FOR NOW GO TO THE FRONT LINE ANY
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY
ONE OH NINE YOU MAY PRESSONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY ONE OH
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. WE HAVE NO COMMENT IN A
POSITION OF AB TWENTY ONE OH
NINE. GREAT ANY QUESTION. A
QUESTION TWENTY MISTER SMITH YES
THANK YOU BUT I WAS SENT A FEW
OF THEM ARE WILLING TO TAKE HIM
MEMBERS WHERE WOULD LET LOWER.
OR NARROW THE LANGUAGE WITHIN
SECTION ONE. THAT SOLD AT THE
BAIT LURE OR CHARM FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ATTRACTING LIKE
SHARKS IS PROHIBITED ONE MARKET
STRUCTURE YOU THE VISIBLE. ARE
KNOWN TO BE PRESENT. THE SUIT
JUST POINT WHERE. THE NOT ABOUT
A PROPOSED BY COMMITTEE BY. WHEN
YOU'RE ASKING. I CERTAINLY AM
WILLING CONSIDER A MEMBER TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE BILL DOES
WHAT WE INTENDED TO DO AND
DOESN'T HAVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES I KNOW THAT THE-
FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATIONS
CONCERNED ABOUT BAIT. I
CERTAINLY NOT GOING TO TAKE THIS
AMENDMENT JUST RIGHT NOW- BUT IT
CERTAINLY WILLING TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD- TO SEE IF THERE
IS- A- WAY TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS. WHAT I'M CONCERNED
WITH ON THE OTHER SIDE IS ONCE
YOU CREATE AN EXCEPTION LIKE
THAT PUTS TO HAVE UNSCRUPULOUS
OPERATORS SAY ALL WERE REALLY
FISHING FOR SHARKS- WHEN AND
REALLY IN FACT STATE THEY ITS
WINK WINK AND IT REALLY THEY'RE
TRYING TO DO THE FUTURE. I'M
TRYING TO BALANCE. THOSE TWO
THINGS AS WE GO FORWARD THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS NOW I
KNOW. FOR MANY FISH WILDLIFE IS
ONLINE FOR QUESTIONS OF THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE VIRTUALLY-
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO COOK
MISTER BENNETT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF RESPECTFULLY- REQUEST-
AND I VOTE. THANK YOU AT AND WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND SO
WILL CALL THE ROLL THANK. THE
MOTION IS THE PAST
APPROPRIATIONS BARRICADE HAN AYE
BARRICADE. AYE DOLLY. DOLLY NOT
VOTING BENNETT AYE BENNETT AYE
BIGELOW FRIEDMAN GARCIA GARCIA I
KALRA LEVINE MURATSUCHI WHEN
RUBIO. RUBIO AYE SALAS SMITH
SMITH NOT VOTING. THE APPROVED
WHAT THE VALLAPUDUA I WARD. THE
PHONE CALL BILL HAS FIVE AT IT'S
ON CALL WE WILL KEEP. THE RIVER
MOTION SECOND AB SO IN I WILL
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO A PRO.
BARRICADE HI ERICA HAND I DOLLY
DALI I SENATE HI SENATE I BIG.
FRIEDMAN GARCIA GARCIA I CALLED
. LEVINE MURATSUCHI. WHEN RUBIO
RUBIO I SALAS SMITH SMITH I BE
APPROVED WHAT THE VALLAPUDUA II
WARD. DO I HAVE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. CAVERNA SECOND
HAVE AGAIN THANK GALLAGHER
THAT'S AB TWENTY SEVENTY EIGHT
FLOOR AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY SEVEN
STONE AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE
MISS RUBIO AND AB TWENTY SIXTEEN
THE CHURCH ITSELF. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL BARRICADE HAND HI
BARRICADE HAND I DOLLY DALI I.
BENNETT. BANNON I BIGELOW
FRIEDMAN GARCIA GARCIA I KALRA
LEVINE MURATSUCHI WHEN RUBIO
RUBIO AYE SALAS SMITH SMITH I BE
APPROVED WHAT THE VALLAPUDUA I
WARD. MISTER BLOOM YOU ARE UP
NEXT AB TWENTY FIVE. OCANA GOING
BY. OKAY WELL MISTER BLUE IN
FILER MISTER WEST FOR. ASSEMBLY
BLOOM IS C. TO MISTER MOORE
MISTER. THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM.
SO WE WILL AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY
NINE BY MISTER KIRK WHEN YOU'RE
READY- THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. BOB I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
THOROUGH THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS.
SHOULD DISPEL MOVE OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE I WILL ACT ON THE
COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDATION AND
CLARIFY THAT GROUNDWATER
RECHARGE. RECHARGE PROJECTS ARE
EXCLUDED FROM THIS BILL. SO I'M
TAKING THE- SUGGESTED AMENDMENT
. THE BAY DELTA ESTUARY IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO
CALIFORNIA FOR MANY REASONS.
VICE DRINKING WATER TO OVER
TWENTY NINE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
. ATION TO FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION ACRES OF FARMLAND AND
CRITICAL HABITAT FOR MANY NATIVE
SPECIES. THE STATE WATER BOARD
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR PROTECTING
THE WATER IN THE BAY DELTA. BY
DROPPING AND IMPLEMENTING WATER
QUALITY OBJECTIVES AS PART OF
THE BAY DELTA WATER QUALITY
CONTROL PLAN OR FAIL TO PLAN.
THIS PLAN WAS ADOPTED IN
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE NEARLY
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS AGO. SINCE
THEN THE IMPACT OF DROUGHT AND
CLIMATE. HAVE BEGUN TO WRECK
HAVOC ON THE DELTA. COUPLED WITH
OTHER FACTORS THIS IS DRIVEN
SOME NATIVE FISH TO THE BRINK OF
EXTINCTION EXTINCTION AND
PROBABLY TO EXTINCTION. WHEN THE
WATER BOARD STARTED THE MOST
RECENT UPDATES TO THE BAY DELTA
PLAN IN TWO THOUSAND NINE. YOU
COULD STILL FIND DELTA SMELT IN
THE DELTA. NOW THEY HAVE NOT
BEEN SEEN IN THE WILD FOR THE
PAST FOUR YEARS. REPORTS BY
WATER LAW EXPERTS AND THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE FOUND
THAT UPDATES THE BAY DELTA
PLANNER URGENTLY NEEDED TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S DRINKING
WATER. NATIVE FISH AND THE
WATERSHED ITSELF FROM WORSENING
THREATS IMPOSED BY CLIMATE
CHANGE AND DROUGHT. THE LACK OF
MODERN WATER QUALITY STANDARDS
ALSO HURTS LONG TERM PLANNING
FOR WATER PROJECTS BY CREATING
UNCERTAINTY THAT IS IN NINETEEN
NINETY SIX NINETEEN NINETY FIVE.
YOU COULD HAVE SAID- YOU CAN
IMPROVE MY PLOT I REQUEST FOR
WATER FROM THE DELTA BECAUSE
THERE IS AN ESTABLISHED PLAN
THERE REALLY IS THE ESTABLISH
PLAN NOW IS JUST TOO LONG AGO.
AND YOU CAN'T REALLY QUOTED SO
IT IS ACTUALLY HARDER RIGHT NOW
TO GET WATER RIGHTS AND IT WOULD
BE IF THE PLAN WERE UPDATED.
THIS PLAN A CO DEFIES THE
CURRENT GOAL OF THE STATE WATER
BOARD TO ADOPT AND IMPLEMENT AN
UPDATE TO THE BAY DOWN TO PLANT.
BY THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. FOR A START. AND IT'S TO
ADOPT ENABLE UP TO THE BAY DELTA
PLAN. AS AN INCENTIVE. THE BILL
IN PRINT PAUSES EXTENDING HER A
SHE KNEW WATER RIGHTS THAT WOULD
DIVERT ADDITIONAL FLOW AWAY FROM
THE DELTA. TO THESE WATER RIGHTS
PERMITS CAN BE ASSESSED USING
CONTEMPORARY STANDARDS. MOVING
FORWARD I CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE STAKEHOLDERS FROM THE
APOLLO. FROM THE OPPOSITION-
UNLESS AMENDED COALITION TO
AVOID UNINTENDED IMPACTS TO
PROJECTS THAT ARE CRITICAL FOR
DROUGHT MANAGEMENT. IN THE
FUTURE I TEND TO MAKE TWO
ADDITIONAL CHANGES WHICH STARTED
DRESSED CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION THESE CHANGES WILL
CLARIFY THAT THE MORATORIUM ON
WATER RIGHTS WILL ONLY GO INTO
EFFECT IF THE WATER BOARD MRS
THE DEADLINE. TO ADOPT THE BAY
DELTA PLAN WHICH WAS THE
ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE BILL BUT
WILL CLARIFY THAT THAT'S THE
CASE FURTHER OUR MOVE THE
MORATORIUM ON EXTENDING CERTAIN
WATER RIGHTS TO REDUCE IMPACTS
TO WATER TRANSFERS AN EXISTING
PROJECTS THAT ARE NEEDED FOR
DROUGHT MANAGEMENT. THE POINT IS
THOUGH THAT WE NEED SOME SORT OF
INCENTIVE. FOR THE BOARD TO
CONTINUE THEY'VE ALREADY MISSED
MANY DEADLINES BECAUSE THE PLAN
SHOULD HAVE BEEN UPDATED AND IT
HASN'T AND WE HAVE FELT THE
IMPACT. WITH ME TODAY IS JONAS
MILTON FROM THE PLANNING THE
CONSERVATION LEAD AND RICHARD
FRANK FROM THE UC DAVIS SCHOOL
OF LAW LET ME ALSO POINT OUT
THAT I AM WILLING WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO COME UP WITH
ALTERNATIVE. INCENTIVES AND- WE
WILL CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT THAT
AS WE DID LAST NIGHT WHEN I MADE
THESE. THESE CHANGES TO THE BILL
WHICH WE WILL TAKE IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU AND AGAIN
AND- WHOSE FIRST. OKAY- MR
ROBERTS FRANK FRANK FROM THE UC
DAVIS SCHOOL OF LAW THANK YOU DR
PARK MANAGER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- I AM A PROFESSOR OF
AND- OF LAW AT UC DAVIS SCHOOL
OF LAW WHERE I TEACH WATER
LAUNCH HERBAL NATURAL RESOURCES-
COURSES IN ADDITION TO THAT ON
THE FORMER CHIEF DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND MOST
RELEVANT- IN NINETEEN TWENTY ONE
AND EARLIER THIS YEAR I
COLLABORATED WITH OTHER WHAT OUR
PROFESSORS FROM STANFORD
BERKELEY AND MIKE GEORGE. AND
OTHER WATER LAW EXPERTS ON A
BACKGROUND REPORT AND A SET OF
RECOMMENDATIONS BY DEFYING TO
UPDATE CALIFORNIA'S ANTIQUATED
ABOVE WATER RIGHTS LAW SYSTEM AT
THE CRYPTIC HE PUT. I'M SORRY.
THE STATE YOU GET THAT THANK YOU
FOR HI MISSPOKE. MY CHILDREN
TELL ME I'M A PRISONER THE PAST
THANK YOU THAT RIGHT. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND- THIS YEAR- ON
BACKGROUND REPORT IS A
RECOMMENDATIONS THE PENDING BILL
IS PART OF OUR ONE OF THE
SEVERAL BILLS. PENDING TO
INCORPORATE AND ADOPT SOME OF
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS- AS AS DR
CORPORATES INDICATED SPEND OVER
A QUARTER CENTURY. SINCE THE
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE- BAY DELTA
PLAN HAS BEEN UPDATED TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS- IN FACT. IN THE
MEANTIME IS THE WATER BOARD
ITSELF IS LIKE KNOWLEDGE THAT
BACK IN- TWENTY EIGHTEEN COULD
RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR A QUOTE
URGENT EFFORTS IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY SACRAMENTO SAN
JOAQUIN DELTA ESTUARY. TO
ADDRESS PROLONGED A PRECIPITOUS
DECLINES. OF NATIVE AKPATA
SPECIES AND THE ECOSYSTEM- THEY
DEPEND ON. OF THE STATE WATER
CODE ALREADY CONTAINS
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE WATER
QUALITY PLANTS INCLUDING THIS
ONE BE UPDATED PERIODICALLY
REGULARLY- THE FEDERAL CLEAN
WATER ACT UNDER WHICH THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. HAS DELEGATED
AUTHORITY FROM U. S. EPA TO
ADOPT WATER QUALITY PLANS
REQUIRES THOSE KIND OF RE
EVALUATIONS AND UPDATES EVERY
THREE YEARS. SO. IS DEFINITELY
OUT OF COMPLIANCE THERE STATE
WATER BOARDS IS TO. THAT IT AND
THE WATER BOARD CAN COME. THE
BAY DELTA UPDATE BEFORE THE END
OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE- AND-
THE- MEANWHILE- THE AS DR
CORPORATES MENTIONED AB MY
FACULTY COLLEAGUES UC DAVIS
PETER MOYLE THE STATE'S. MOST
PROMINENT FISHERIES SCIENTIST
HAS OUR REPORT CHRONICLED THE
DECLINE OF THE DELTA ESTUARY THE
EXTINCTION OF SPECIES IN THE
FACT THAT UP TO ONE HUNDRED OF
DELTA.
WITHOUT A DIRECT AND- ROMPED
ACTION. IN SOME TO QUOTE OUR
WORKING GROUP RIGHT- THE STATE'S
FAILURE DURING THE LAST QUARTER
CENTURY TO ADOPT AND IMPLEMENT
REVISED FOR ST FLOOR JACK IS FOR
THE BAY DELTA ESTUARY REPRESENTS
A AN UNACCEPTABLE PUBLIC POLICY
FAILURE FAILURE FOR THAT REASON
BUT- I URGE AN AFFIRMATIVE VOTE
THANK YOU AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. GOOD MORNING. I'M
MINTON SENIOR WATER POLICY. THE
PLAN CONCERT LEAGUE BUT PRIOR TO
THAT I WAS ACTUALLY WATER
PROJECT DEVELOPER. WHO WAS
SUCCESSFUL IN OBTAINING WATER
RIGHTS FROM THE STATE BOARD.
AFTER TWENTY SEVEN YEARS NOW
WHAT'S THE BIG HURRY. THERE ARE
TWO REASONS. FIRST THE ICONIC
SPECIES WHEN A RUN SPRING RUN
SALMON ARE LITERALLY ON THE
BRINK OF EXTINCTION. AND THIS IS
NOT LIKE THE MOVIE JURASSIC PARK
. WHERE SCIENTISTS CAN GO REACH
INTO THE FREEZER FOR PRESERVED
SPECIMEN. AND CALL IT BACK INTO
LIFE. EXTINCTION IS FOREVER.
SECOND OUTDATED STANDARDS MEANS
THERE IS NO REGULATORY CERTAINTY
FOR WATER PROJECT DEVELOPERS.
THIS STATE WATER BOARD IS
REQUIRED BY SEVERAL LAWS TO
JUDGE THE IMPACT ON THE
ENVIRONMENT AND ON OTHER WATER
USERS. WATER DISTRICTS BUT I'M
LITERALLY MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ASSESSING THOSE IMPACT. BUT
WITHOUT CONTEMPORARY STANDARDS
THEY HAVE NO REGULATORY
CERTAINTY. NOW THIS IS NOT JUST
A THEORETICAL PROBLEM. ONE MAJOR
SURFACE WATER PROJECT WHAT STUCK
IN OVER A YEAR OF HEARINGS AT
THE STATE BOARD CHASING THE
GHOSTS OF OUTDATED STANDARDS.
WITHOUT CONTEMPORARY STANDARDS
THEY COULD NOT ASSURED THEIR OWN
WATER USERS. THAT THE PROJECT
WOULD PROVIDE EVEN A SINGLE DROP
OF ADDITIONAL WATER TO THEM MR
FOR YOU NEED TO TALK INTO THE
MIKE THANK YOU. THEY FINALLY
WITHDREW THEIR APPLICATION TO
COME BACK ANOTHER YEAR. WITHOUT
REGULATORY CERTAINTY THE OTHER
SURFACE WATER PROJECTS THAT ARE
LINED UP FOR APPROVAL WILL FACE
THE SAME HURDLES. THAT'S WHY WE
JOIN YOUR LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND ARE FINDING THAT
UPDATING WATER QUALITY
OBJECTIVES THE BAY DELTA
WATERSHED IS LONG OVERDUE AND
SHOULD BE A HIGH PRIORITY FOR
THE STATE TO COMPLETE. AFTER
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTY NINE IS NECESSARY TO
PROVIDE THAT REGULATORY
CERTAINTY THANK YOU. CAN KILL
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT HERE IN
THE ROOM OR IN THE HALLWAY.
SEEING NONE FOR NOW WE CAN GO TO
THE PHONE LINES. ANY SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE LINES. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY NINE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SIX THIRTY NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO. NINE
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR- CAN DELFINO ON
BEHALF OF DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU
. NINE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE SIXTEEN
YOU MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND
WE'LL MOVE ON TO LINE FORTY TWO
ONE FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU PETER
DIRECTOR WITH THE TOLD ME RIVER
TRAFFIC IN SUPPORT. AND
APPRECIATE THE OFFER. NINE
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE THIRTY
YEAH MAYBE IT SO YOUR- DOES HE
HAVE TO CALL ON BEHALF OF THE
PLANNING CONSERVATION LEAGUE
PASS A DIFFICULT FEDERATION OF
FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATION CENTER
FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
SACRAMENTO RIVER COUNCIL AND
CALIFORNIA WATER RESEARCH ALL IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY
NINE THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER LINES IN Q. IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY NINE
THANK YOU AND IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE HAVE
SOMEONE HERE FROM AUCKLAND TO
TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU CHERUB OUR KEY HUNG IN
MEMBERS CINDY TECH WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES WE REPRESENT PUBLIC
WATER AGENCIES ACROSS THE STATE
THEY'RE ALL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WE
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL WE'VE MET
TWO TIMES WITH ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK AND WE APPRECIATE HIS TIME
IN MEETING WITH US IN THE
AMENDMENTS THAT HE HAS AGREED TO
MAKE- ONE QUESTION I IN HIS
CLOTHES MAYBE IF HE COULD
ADDRESS- WE UNDERSTOOD FROM THE
MEETING LAST NIGHT THAT HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT EXCLUDING. THE
EXTENSION OF TIME FOR EXISTING
PERMITS FROM THE WATER RIGHTS
MORATORIUM SO CLEAR IF-
CLARIFICATION ON THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL WE STILL BELIEVE THE
LINES THAT ARE PROPOSED IN
DIVISION A AND B. SHOULD BE
AMENDED AS WE SUGGESTED IN OUR
MOCK UP ON THE WATER RIGHTS
PROVISION- IF IT'S NERO TO NEW
WATER RIGHTS PERMITS WE STILL
ARE STRONGLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT AND IF IT'S BROADER TO
INCLUDE EXTENSIONS EVEN MORE
CONCERNED THE WATER RIGHTS
MORATORIUM IS COUNTER PRODUCTIVE
HALTING WATER RIGHTS- TAKES AWAY
A TOOL THAT THE AGENCIES NEED TO
MANAGE WATER AS YOU ALL KNOW
MANAGING WATER INCOME. ONE
EXAMPLE OF THE CONCERNED ABOUT
IS A DELAY SITES RESERVOIR
THAT'S A PROJECT THAT IS GOOD
FOR SALMON IN THE SACRAMENTO
VALLEY AREA IT'S GOOD FOR PEOPLE
IT'S GOOD FOR GROWING CROPS. ON
ONE OF THOSE MULTI BENEFIT
PROJECTS THAT THE STATE NEEDS.
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT- DELAYING
PROJECTS IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY THAT WILL HELP
COMMUNITIES HAVE SAFE DRINKING
WATER A RELIABLE SUPPLY OF SAFE
DRINKING WATER. THERE'S
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THE WAY
THE BILL IS CURRENTLY DRAFTED
AND IS STILL BEING PROPOSED TO
BE AMENDED. IN WHAT WE
UNDERSTAND THE BILL TO BE WE
URGE A NO VOTE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS RYAN OR
JACKING WITH THE REGIONAL WATER
AUTHORITY- RWA IS TWENTY MEMBERS
OF DRINKING WATER SUPPLIERS THAT
SUPPLY WATER TO TWO MILLION
PEOPLE IN THE GREATER SACRAMENTO
AREA. OUR PRIMARY FOCUS IN
ACHIEVING OUR MISSION WHICH IS
THE RELIABLE DELIVERY- OF HIGH
QUALITY AFFORDABLE WATER IS
ADAPTING TO CLIMATE CHANGE WHICH
I THINK YOU KNOW IS BEHIND THE
REASON WHY MR CORK IS BRINGING
THE BILL FORWARD. FOR A LARGE
PART ONE LIKE THE COMMITTEE TO
BE AWARE OF IS THAT WHILE WE
TALK ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE
REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF OVERALL
WATER SUPPLY WHAT REALLY CLIMATE
CHANGES IS WREAKING IN THE
NORTHERN PART OF THE STATE IS A
CHANGE IN OUR PRECIPITATION
PATTERNS. SO WE'RE MOVING AWAY
FROM PRECIPITATION PATTERNS THAT
WERE BASED ON SNOW PACKED THAT
CHANGES THE WAY THAT OUR SYSTEM
FUNCTIONS AND THAT THEN CASCADES
INTO RAMIFICATIONS ON WATER
RIGHTS AND HOW WATER RIGHTS PLAY
OUT AND THAT'S REALLY THE BIG.
CONCERN THAT WE HAVE WITH THE
BILL. IN OUR REGION OUR PRIMARY
WAY OF ADAPTING CALL CAME. SHIP
NOPE. REGIME DOWN TO EIGHT WATER
REGIME. WE CAN DO THAT IF WE
MAKE IT JUST TO OUR WAY RIGHTS
AND FRANKLY WHAT IT WHAT IT
COMES DOWN TO IS TAKING THOSE
BIG STORM EVENTS SO LIKE WE HAD
A BIG STORM EVENT THIS YEAR EVEN
THOUGH IT'S GOING TO BE. A DRY
YEAR WE HAD BIG STUFF EVENTS
OCTOBER AND IN DECEMBER AND WE
HAVE OPPORTUNITIES TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE STORM OF THE
HANDS AND MOVE THOSE INTO THE
GROUND NOW I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
AUTHOR IS LOOKING TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THOSE ISSUES. AND I
THINK WE'RE MAKING REALLY GOOD
PROGRESS BUT WE STILL HAVE A
LITTLE WAYS TO GO YET- AGAIN
APPRECIATE ALL OF THOSE EFFORT-
AND- I THINK I'LL WRAP UP THERE
AND JUST SAY YOU KNOW AT THIS
POINT IN TIME WE REMAIN IN AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION-
IS BECAUSE OF THE IMPACTS THAT
THE BILL COULD HAVE ON OUR
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE AND ARM
PLANT INFRASTRUCTURE. THANK YOU-
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION HERE IN THE
ROOM OR OUTSIDE OF THE ROOM. NOT
SEEING ANY WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES OPERATE OR ANY OPPOSITION
ON THE PHONE LINES. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY
SIX THIRTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTY NINE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. NINE FORTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I APOLOGIZE I MISSED THE
US SUPPORT FOR THE AIRLINES CARE
HOW CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SIX THIRTY NINE THANK YOU
. NINE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ARK NO DOCTOR THAT'S
REPRESENTING SANTA CLARA VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT IN OUR BOARD HAS
TAKEN AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION OUT OF CONCERN THAT THE
WATER RIGHT CRIBBAGE PROVISIONS
MAY INTERFERE WITH MODERATES
APPROVALS CRITICAL TO OUR
VALLEY- WERE ALSO CONCERNED
ABOUT MAY NOT ACCOMMODATE THE
VOLUNTEERS. NEEDED WHICH SHOULD
MAKE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IN
RECENT WEEKS WE REALLY
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRKS ARE WILLING TO WORK WITH
US AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE DISCUSSION THANK
YOU. NINE FOURTEEN. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GO. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ARE COMMITTEE THIS IS-
DEAN MARKLEY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU AND WE ALIGN- ARE
COMMON OURSELF WITH THE COMMENTS
OF SHOULD TUCK AND AQUA. NINE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- I AM DAVID
CARR C. WITH THE BELLAVISTA
WATER DISTRICT CALLING TO-
RECOMMEND OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NINE TWENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF HIS GOVERNMENT
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO THE
AMERICAN COUNCIL OF ENGINEERING
COMPANIES CALIFORNIA- WE AGREE
THAT THEY DON'T PLAN UPDATES ARE
LONG OVERDUE BUT ITS BUSINESS AT
THIS TIME MUST RESPECT BECAUSE-
OF THE RECENT EXPRESSED BY MR
PARKS THE CIVIC WITH THE TYING
OF THE PLANNED UPDATES TO THE
NEW WATER. PERFECT SO I WILL
LOOK AT THE MOMENT STAND FORWARD
TO WORKING PROPERLY BEFORE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M GOING FORTY
FIVE JUST SAY YOUR NAME AND YOUR
POSITION. YOUR ORGANIZATION YOUR
POSITION PLEASE. ONE FORTY. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO. WHAT ARE
MARKET. HELP NINE FORTY ONE YOUR
MIND OPEN GO AHEAD. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT SOUTH
NINE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO. MORE
BRENDA BACK WITH FIFTEEN HELP
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN A UNLESS
SOMEONE TO POSITION ALONG AQUA.
THANK YOU. FIND ONE YOUR LINE IS
A PLEASE GO AHEAD. SLUMBER PARTY
LIVE FROM TEL WATER YOU MAY HAVE
YOUR- BACK ON MY FORTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU. BUT
AGRICULTURE SECTOR AND ONE FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD
. SIR YES MY NAME'S NAME GALA
APOLOGIZE I AM NOT CALLING IN
SOME SO. OF THE BILL I'M NOT AN
AND WE CAN DOORS THANK. THE NEW. WHEN NO FURTHER COMMENTS
OFFICE OF THE TWENTY SO THIRTY
NINE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
THEN I'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THE SURVEY BUT WHAT. SO THE
QUESTION THAT WAS BROUGHT UP-
JUST MINUTES AGO. IN AS PROPOSAL
WATER RIGHTS MORATORIUM WITH A
DELAY SITE RESERVE RESERVOIRS
AND DELAY WATER PROJECTS IN THE
VALLEY. THE QUESTIONS FOR A YES
WANTED TO SHOW OUR INTENTION IS-
WE'RE FINE WITH SITES WE DO NOT
WISH TO INADVERTENTLY- CHANGE
THAT WE DON'T BELIEVE THE BILL
AS WRITTEN DOES BUT WE WILL
CHECK TO MAKE SURE- AND WE WILL
ALSO BE LISTENING TO WHAT
ADEQUATE AND- THE REST OF THE
OPPOSITION HAS TO SAY. BOB BUT
THE INTENTION IS THAT NONE OF
THESE CONSEQUENCES COME INTO
AFFECT. THAT'S THE INTENTION BUT
THEY HAVE TO BE STRONG ENOUGH
THAT THE BOARD STOPS MISSING
DEADLINES AND YOU KNOW THEY'RE
REQUIRED BY LAW TO UP TO DO
DRESSES JERRY UPDATES THEY
HAVEN'T DONE THEM SO IT NEEDS A
STRONG AND AGAIN I'M WILLING TO
WORK WITH ACWA FOR OTHER STRONG
THINGS LIKE MAYBE WITHHOLDING
SALARIES BUT I DON'T THINK
THAT'S- LEGAL- BUT- HE COULD DO
IT TO US WHEN WE MISSED THE
BUDGET BUT I'M NOT SURE YOU
COULD DO A PLOY EASE. SO WE NEED
TO HAVE SOME TO MAKE SOMETHING
HAPPEN THAT THIS REALLY WILL
TAKE PLACE MY INTENTION IS THAT
NONE OF THESE. EVER GO INTO
EFFECT. I JUST I JUST HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THIS BILL JUST
BECAUSE I THINK IT DELAYS
PROJECTS IN THE VALLEY. YOU KNOW
SO MOVING FORWARD I DON'T WANT
TO LATEST PROJECTS WE ACTUALLY
WILL PARTY UP PROJECTS BECAUSE
THEY'RE VAN B. FOR EXAMPLE THE
SACRAMENTO FOLKS SAID THAT WE
WANT TO CHANGE WHAT WE'RE DOING
RIGHT NOW. AND BECAUSE OF THE
CHANGE IN THE CLIMATE AND YES
THERE'S MUCH MORE RAIN RATHER
THAN SNOW. IF WE HAVE A STANDARD
THAT IS ADOPTED THEN THE
REGIONAL WATER BOARD WILL BE
ABLE TO SAY AHA WE MEET THE NEW
STANDARD YOU CAN IMPROVE OUR
PLAN AND POTENTIALLY CAN GO MUCH
FASTER SO THAT'S ANOTHER REASON
WHY WE WANT THIS TO HAPPEN AND
HAPPEN IN A WAY THAT DOES NOT
BRING ABOUT ANY OF THE
CONSEQUENCES BUT IN FACT BRINGS
ABOUT AN AGREEMENT. AT THE END
OF THE SITE NEXT YEAR THANK YOU
. THREE PURDUE ARE YOU. VERY OF
CONFLICT THANK YOU THIS RUN ITS
- THANK YOU. IF YOU KNOW MY I'D
LIKE TO ASK OF THE WITNESSES
CHAIR WITH UP AND OF I WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE THE WITNESSES
ANSWER THIS QUESTION AND THAT IS
THAT. IF IS THERE A TIME WHEN AN
ACT OF A LOGICAL ACCOUNTABILITY
BILL LIKE WHAT THE DOCTOR
CORKAGE THIS PROPOSING HERE-
WOULD NOT HAVE SOME. POTENTIAL
TO DELAY NOT HAVE SOME POTENTIAL
TO HAVE WATER IMPACTS ME MY
POINT HERE IS THAT WE'VE BEEN
WAITING A LONG TIME AND A VERY
GOOD CASES MADE THAT. YOU
SHOULDN'T JUST ALLOW PEOPLE TO
JUST KEEP KICKING THE CAN DOWN
THE ROAD ON THE PLAN. NO MATTER
WHEN WE FINALLY SAY ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH AND WE NEED TO HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY. AN ARGUMENT
COULD BE MADE A YEAR FROM NOW IF
WE WERE GONNA DO THAT TWO YEARS
FROM NOW THAT ANOTHER PROJECT
WOULD BE POTENTIALLY DELAYED AND
I SHAPE ONLY POTENTIALLY BUILD
DELAYED BECAUSE AS DR CORPORATES
OUT OF EVERYBODY DOES WHAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO. THERE
SHOULDN'T BE DELAY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT DETAILED MANY OF THESE
CONSEQUENCES ONLY COME IF THEY
DON'T D THAT DON'T DO THAT SUCH
AS THAT THAT HYPOTHETICAL. SO IS
THERE SOME WINDOW WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE COULD FINALLY SAY
YOU KNOW FINALLY THERE'S GOING
TO BE A CONSEQUENCE FOR NOT
DOING WHAT STATE LAW SAYS YOU
SHOULD HAVE BEEN DOING FOR. A
LONG TIME IS THERE IS THERE EVER
A WINDOW WHEN WE CAN DO THAT OR
WILL THERE ALWAYS BE. THIS
POTENTIAL THAT THERE'S GONNA BE
SOME DELAY SOME WATER RIGHTS
QUESTION EXCEPT FOR. WELL THE
REASON WE TOOK AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION IS BECAUSE WE
RECOGNIZE THAT IT HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANT TIME. AND THEIR
NEEDS TO BE AN END DATE. BUT WE
SUGGESTED THAT SUBDIVISION AB
CHANGE TO HIS SOON AS
PRACTICABLE. BECAUSE WERE
CONCERNED THAT THE DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST DEADLINE IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. WHICH CAME FROM A
STATE WATER BOARD STAFF
PRESENTATION I DON'T BELIEVE THE
STATE WATER BOARD ITSELF HAS
SAID. IN A WHICH PATHWAY WITH A
WANNA USE WHICH STATE DO THEY
THINK THEY CAN MAKE. SO I THINK
THAT'S AN OPEN QUESTION. BUT
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT THE
DEADLINE BEING PROPOSED CUTS THE
PUBLIC PROCESS PART YOU KNOW
YOU. YOU CAN'T JAM THE PUBLIC
PROCESS AT THE END WE NEED TO
HAVE COMMITMENT THAT THE PUBLIC
AT MY PART PARDON ME FOR
HAPPENED JUST NO TIME IS JUST
ABOUT I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU
THINK THE DEADLINE. IS TOO SOON
BUT MY QUESTION ONLY IS THERE
SOME WINDOW WHERE THERE WOULD
NOT BE THESE CONCERNS. SO I
THINK IT DEPENDS ON THE PROCESS
THAT YOU GET TO THE END POINT
RIGHT SO I THINK THAT THE
BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING EVEN
THOUGH THE BILL'S RELATIVELY
SHORT THREE SUBDIVISIONS. IT
HIT- COMES INTO A PROCESS THAT
HAS BEEN IN PLAY FOR TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS AND DISRUPTS WATER
RIGHT AND LAW THAT HAS BEEN IN
PLACE SINCE THE FOUNDATION OF
THE STATE RIGHT SO. IF THE
PROCESS BY WHICH WE GET TO THAT
AMPULLAE. THAT'S THAT'S THE REAL
CHALLENGE RIGHT BECAUSE YOU KNOW
AS A FAMILY MEMBER VEHICLE WHO I
WAS ASKING ABOUT THE
RAMIFICATIONS ON PROJECTS. WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
HAVING THE LEAST RAMIFICATIONS
ARE PROJECTS ESPECIALLY THOSE
CLIMATE ADAPTATION PROJECTS AND
SO. YOUR YOUR QUESTION IS A
GREAT QUESTION BUT I THINK IT'S
THE CORE OF THE BELT THAT WE
REALLY NEED TO WORK THROUGH TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE BILL IS
CONSIDERING THE PROCESS BY WHICH
WE GET TO THE END POINT. AND SO
THAT'S THAT'S THE REAL CHALLENGE
BECAUSE WE'RE ACCELERATING A
PROCESS WHERE THERE'S A VARIETY
OF PATHWAYS. AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE TAKE TIME TO GET
THAT PROCESS RIGHT. AND THAT ALL
VOICES ARE HEARD IN THAT PROCESS
AND THEN WE DON'T DESERVE
CITIZENSHIP SO FOR ME THE
QUESTION THAT I HAVE A SET. OF
WE AN ASSEMBLY WHO IS WILLING TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE PROCESS. BUT SHOULD WE
BEGIN THE PROCESS OF SAYING HEY
ACCOUNTABILITY IS COMING. AND
WE- NEED TO DO SOMETHING TO
BRING THIS TO AN END. AND SO. TO
IDENTIFY THAT WELL WE DON'T WANT
TO DATE WE WANT TO SAY AS SOON
AS PRACTICABLE. AND COMBINE THAT
WITH THE FOR HIS LEGACY BY MOTOR
FINANCE. IF I IF I COULD IF IT
IS AS IS AS SOON AS PRACTICABLE.
JUST ALLOWS SOMEBODY TO KICK THE
CAN DOWN THE ROAD BY SAYING
WHAT'S NOT PRACTICAL YET BECAUSE
WE'VE GOT THE SITES RESERVOIRS
NOT PRACTICAL YET BECAUSE WE
HAVE THIS- WE HAVE A- I THINK A
GOOD FAITH EFFORT BEING MADE TO
SAVE. THERE WILL BE AN EFFORT TO
WORK WITH YOU ON THE PROCESS AND
TO MAKE THAT DISTINCTION- GOOD
FAITH EVER TRY TO WORK ON THE
PROCESS BUT- AT LEAST. IF WE
DON'T BEGIN THE PROCESS NOW OF
ACCOUNTABILITY. MY QUESTION IS
WHEN DO WE BEGIN THE PROCESS OF
ACCOUNTABILITY BECAUSE THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS. JUST ABOUT BEEN
FILLED TO THE TOP WITH.
CONSTANTLY A SENSE OF THERE IS A
LACK OF ACCOUNTABILITY TO FOLLOW
THROUGH ON STATE. MANDATED
DUTIES OF VARIOUS AGENCIES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU MISTER
BANNISTER LEVINE YOUR QUESTION.
YEAH I THINK OF A FEW. I WANTED
CALL UP THE WITNESSES THAT-
PROVIDED TEST I THINK SOMEONE
GOT A PHONE CALL BUT- THERE IS A
MENTION OF- YOU KNOW AN
EXTINCTION LEVEL EVENT FOR
SMELTS- THAT. YOU KNOW WE MANY
OF US. MANY OF US I WAS IN
OFFICE FOR- HENDO IS ON THIS
COMMITTEE- AS WE SAW THAT THE
NUMBERS DWINDLE I CAN'T BELIEVE
I AM PEOPLE PERSON ON THIS
COMMITTEE- THAT THAT'S HOW TIME
FLIES- SO. YOU KNOW THIS IS A
TWENTY SEVEN YEAR DELAYED. YOU
KNOW PLAN THAT DOCTOR QUIRK IS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE-
GET THIS THING GOING HOW DO WE-
NOT PRESIDE OVER EXTINCTION
LEVEL EVENTS. AND I THINK THAT
PERHAPS. BY THE TIME WE WERE IN
A POLICY MAKING. POSITION AND WE
HAVE THE LAST DROUGHT. THAT- THE
CARD HAD ALREADY BEEN DEALT-
THAT THAT PERHAPS IT WAS TOO
LATE TO HAVE THE IN AN
INTERVENTION- THAT WOULD HAVE
CHANGED THE OUTCOME- SO I WANT
TO ASK YOU YOU KNOW. TO LOOK
BACK AND SAY WHAT WOULD HAVE
THAT WINDOW OF TIME BEEN TO
MAYBE NOT THAT THIS ALONE WOULD
HAVE SOLVED THE PROBLEM. BUT
WHAT WE'RE WITH THAT WINDOW OF
TIME HAVE BEEN AND IF YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THAT WHAT IS THE
PARALLEL TODAY. THAT THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT THAT WE COULD HAVE
IMPACTS OF COURSES BILLS MUCH
BIGGER THAN THAN ONLY. AND I
DON'T WANT TO SAY ONLY
EXTINCTION LEVEL EVENTS FOR ANY
SPECIES- BECAUSE THAT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE- BUT IF YOU
CAN JUST KIND OF PROVIDE SOME
CONTEXT. THE DELTA SMELT. ARE NO
LONGER FOUND IN THE WILD IN
THEIR HABITAT. THERE ARE SOME
THAT ARE BEING KEPT IN TANKS.
DOWN IN THE DELTA THERE'S A AS
YOU RELATED BILL. THAT MIGHT
DEAL WITH THAT LATER. JUSTIN
OKAY THE BILL LATER TODAY AND
YOU CANNOT CHARM FOR THEM- FOR
THAT BILL SO. PROBABLY AROUND
TWENTY FIFTEEN WHEN WERE IN THAT
DROUGHT NOW THAT I KEEP IN MIND
THAT WAS TWENTY YEARS AFTER THE
LAST SUBSTANTIVE UPDATE. IF IT
HAD BEEN ADDRESSED AT THAT TIME
POSSIBLY THE DELTA SMELT WOULD
STILL EXIST. NOW YOUR QUESTION
IS WHERE ARE WE ON THE ARC WITH
SALMON SPRING RUN IT WENT AROUND
SALMON. THEY ARE A THREE YEAR
LIFE CYCLE FISH. SO THEY'RE
THEY'RE BORN TO GO OUT TO THE
OCEAN THEY COME BACK THEY BREED
AGAIN THEY DIE THAT'S THEIR LIFE
CYCLE AND- WE'RE IN THE THIRD
YEAR OF A DROUGHT. THERE MAY BE
A FEW LEFT DOWN 23% OUT MY
GRADING- WHERE WE'RE AT THAT
POINT IF THE STATE BOARD DOESN'T
ACT. LIKELY WE WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO TELL YOU WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
TELL YOUR CHILDREN AND GRAND
CHILDREN IT DOES SALMON EXIST
ANYMORE IT IS THAT CRITICAL
ACCORDING TO THE FISHERY
BIOLOGIST THAT'S WHAT'S AT
STAKE. AND I KNOW I'M GOING TO
DO EVERYTHING I CAN TO HELP
AVOID THAT. OKAY AT THE
MICROPHONE TO SPEAK TO DO IT.
YEAH OKAY- ALL RIGHT WELL THANK
YOU FOR AN EXPLANATION IN THAT
PARALLEL I. YOU KNOW I'M I'M I'M
I'M GONNA VOTE FOR THIS BILL
TODAY- IT IS NOT- YOU KNOW IT'S-
YOU KNOW IN IN MY EXPERIENCE AND
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE TECHNICAL
REALITY OF AND DIFFICULTY OF ALL
THAT THIS BILL IS ATTEMPTING TO
DO AND HOW YOU KNOW IT'S AS ROOF
IS IT MAY BE BUT HOW. FAR
REACHING AND IMPACTING IT CAN BE
THAT OF COURSE THERE'S MORE WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE AND I IN
DR CORK IS MENTIONED YOU KNOW
WHAT HIS INTENTIONS ARE WHAT HE
IS TRYING TO DO- AND- AND I
RESPECT THAT. THAT THAT THE
EFFORT IN THE POINT OF HIS BILL.
I I ALSO HAVE- LOOKING BACK.
EIGHT YEARS AGO SEVEN YEARS AGO
AT THAT AT THE LAST DROUGHT. AND
THINKING THAT THE MOST THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO DO WAS PASSED ON A
WATER BOND AND DO A GROUND WATER
BILL. I AND I FEEL LIKE WE
MISSED SIGNIFICANT OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THE POLICY MAKING PROCESS
WAS JUST SO COMPLETELY GUMMED UP
THAT THAT WE DIDN'T. WE DID NOT-
ADD TO ADEQUATELY PLAN FOR OR
ANTICIPATE THAT THE NEXT DROUGHT
WAS GOING TO BE MORE SEVERE WITH
COULD BE EVEN WORSE THAN THE
LAST WORST DROUGHT WE'VE EVER
HAD- AND THAT WE WERE PRIMING
OURSELVES TO YET AGAIN JUST YOU
KNOW LESS THAN A DECADE LATER DO
THE VERY LEAST. WE CAN- FOR- OUR
STATE AND FOR PREPARATION FOR-
HOW WE ANTICIPATE- WATER TO COME
TO PEOPLE THAT THAT THAT WE
NEED- THE WATER FOR AND I DO
WANT TO- JUST TAKE A MOMENT OF
LIBERTY TO. EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATE APPRECIATION FOR MR
JACKIE AND EXPLANATION OF THE
WATER SITUATION WE HAVE I WILL
SHARE WITH EVERYONE THAT I WAS
THE BENEFICIARY OF THAT WAS DONE
I HE WAS MY VERY FIRST
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR- WHEN I
FIRST WAS ELECTED IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE- AND I AM
DELIGHTED THAT YOU ARE STAYING
IN THE WATER WORLD- WITH THE
REGIONAL WATER AUTHORITY. AND
THAT- EVEN THOUGH YOU OPPOSE THE
BILL I'M GONNA SUPPORT THE BILL
THE WAY THAT YOU ARE ABLE TO
SHARE YOUR INSIGHT AND WISDOM TO
HELP EXPLAIN THE SITUATION THAT
WE'RE IN- IT'S SOMETHING THAT I
HOPE THAT THIS COMMITTEE AND
EVERYONE IS ABLE TO. ENJOY I'M
SO THANK YOU MR BACK IN- FOR
THAT- SO I YOU KNOW WHAT LET'S
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS WHAT
WE'LL PROBABLY SEE SOME
AMENDMENTS IN THE APPROPRIATIONS
PROCESS AND SO I THINK THAT FOR
THOSE THAT ARE IN OPPOSE. TO
UNDERSTAND HOW IT HOW WE DO THIS
IS ALL EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT
AND I RECOGNIZE FOR EXAMPLE- THE
REGION OF THE STATE THAT I
REPRESENT WHAT ON ON THE STATE
WATER PROJECT- YOU KNOW THEY
WERE NOT IMPACTED BY THIS WORLD
WE'RE KIND OF LIKE NEUTRAL AND
KIND OF HOW WATER IS DEALT WITH.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND YOU
KNOW THE ONE THAT'S BEEN. OF
BENEFIT TO MY PERSPECTIVE ON THE
STATE THAT I CAN KIND OF SEE
THIS WITHOUT HAVING- YOU KNOW AS
MUCH OF A STAKE SO I CAN KIND
OF. FIGURE OUT WHERE THE
BENEFITS ARE GOING TO BE IN AND
WHERE THAT THAT IMPACTS ARE
GOING TO BE- BUT WILL LOOK AT
THIS REALLY CLOSELY OBVIOUS I
CARE AND I'LL WORK WITH THAT
WITH YOU. AS WE REPORT THANK YOU
. THANK YOU MISTER RAMOS PROVIDE
ANOTHER COMMENT YEAH I DO THINK
MANAGER. AS AYE AYES AYE
LISTENING TO MY COLLEAGUES-
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TIMELINE
RIGHT AMIN MIKE MY QUESTION IS
THAT. THE INCENTIVIZE RIGHT OR
IS IT GOING TO CUT CORNERS. AND
IS THE PUBLIC COMMENT GET IT
GOING TO BE INVOLVED THAT'S
IMPORTANT YEAH SO SURE THE
PUBLIC IN FACT THERE WILL BE
MORE DISCLOSURE. IF THIS IS DONE
BY THE WATER BOARD THROUGH
REGULATION AS OPPOSED TO
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT RIGHT NOW
THERE ARE MANY VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS NO ONE'S QUITE SURE
WHAT TENDENCY OF PEOPLE ON THE
SAME WATER BASIN. WHO THERE'S A
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT WITH ONE OF
THE OTHER- SUPPLIERS AND YET
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT'S IN IT SO.
WHAT THIS WILL DO WILL BRING ALL
OF THAT OUT AND MUCH MORE
QUICKLY NOW THE OTHER THING TO
REMEMBER. IS THAT THE STAFF HAS
MADE A PRESENTATION SAYING THAT
THEY ARE READY IN THE FALL OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. THE BOARD
NOT CONTRADICTED THAT SHOULD
THEY DECIDE THAT THEY NEED
ANOTHER YEAR. THEN I'M WILLING
TO DO IT I THINK IT WOULD BE A
MISTAKE BUT I WOULD BE WILLING
TO DO IT SO IF AQUA WANTS TO
CONVINCE- THE WATER BOARD TO
EXTEND THIS. BUT FROM WHAT I
KNOW- TALKING TO THE
ADMINISTRATION- THEY WANT THIS
DONE AND THEY WANT IT DONE.
POSTED IN HASTE AGAIN NONE OF
THESE THINGS HAVE TO HAPPEN IF.
THERE'S BEEN THIRTEEN YEARS OF
THIS I THINK THAT'S LONG ENOUGH
PARTICULARLY SINCE IT'S NOT A
PUBLIC PROCESS RIGHT NOW IN THE
SENSE THAT PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S IN THE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS SO THIRTEEN YEARS
HE'S JUST PLENTY OF TIME. I DO
SEE THAT IT SHOULD GO BEYOND THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE. AS
JUST PROVIDE TO HEAR FROM OKAY
TO SPEAK TO THE POINT REYES BY
THE AUTHOR THE ADMINISTRATION
THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE SEEN THE
MEDIA RELEASED LAST WEEK ON
TUESDAY FROM THE CALIFORNIA
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY IN
CALLIE PA WHERE THE GOVERNOR AND
THE ADMINISTRATION IS-
ANNOUNCING AYMAN NUDE EFFORT. ON
ALL THESE ISSUES AND THEY WANT
TO TAKE AN INTEGRATED APPROACH
WHERE YOU'RE NOT JUST LOOKING AT
FLOWS YOU'RE LOOKING AT HABITAT
YOU'RE DOING ALL THAT WORK
TOGETHER AND- WEBER I READ FROM
THE MEDIA RELEASES THE GOVERNOR
IS YOU KNOW THIS IS A PRIORITY
FOR HIM AND FOR HIS
ADMINISTRATION AND THEY ARE
MOVING FORWARD. THE- MEDIA
RELEASE TALKED ABOUT THAT IF-
WATER AGENCIES WEREN'T SIGNING
ON TO BE A DIFFERENT PROGRAM
THAT WOULD ATTACHED TO THEM SO
THE MINISTRATION IS MOVING BUT-
I THINK IN A DIFFERENT DIRECTION
THAN WHAT WAS JUST DISCUSSED
HERE. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. WHEN
ASKED IF MR BANNON I THINK TO
THE EXTENT THAT THIS IS TO DO A
DELIVER TO LET DELIVERED A FULL
BODY. I HAVE TO- TRY TO RESPOND
A LITTLE BIT TO THAT QUESTION
AND I THINK THAT- YOU KNOW THE I
BRED EARLIER THE ARGUMENT ABOUT
TO THERE MAY NOT BE ENOUGH TIME
FOR PUBLIC INPUT AND THIS IS AT
THE SAME TIME WE HAVE PROJECTS
ARE MOVING FORWARD WITH O
PUBLIC INPUT AND SO IT I THINK
THAT IT IS LEGITIMATE TO SAY
THERE WILL ACTUALLY BE MORE
PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY MORE PUBLIC
AWARENESS MORE PUBLIC INPUT- IF
WE ARE ACTUALLY GOING TO FOCUS
ON A PLAN THAT DOES REQUIRE
THAT. SO JUST WANT TO THROW THAT
OUT THERE- TO THE TO THE EXTENT
THAT IT HELPS AND DID THROW OUT
MY OF MY POSITION WHICH WOULD BE
ITS SUPPORT OF THE BILL BUT BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY SUPPORT OF JUST
CONTINUING TO MOVE THIS FORWARD
WE SEE THIS OVER AND OVER AGAIN
UNTIL A BILL ACTUALLY STARTS TO
MOVE. UNTIL BILL STARTS TO MOVE
YOU JUST DON'T GET THE
COMPROMISES YOU DON'T GET PEOPLE
STEPPING FORWARD AND TRYING TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEMS OF THE ISSUES
THAT ARE BEING ADDRESSED WHAT'S
WHAT IS GOING TO BE IMPACTS ON
ON- WATER RIGHTS WOULD AGAIN BE
THE IMPACTS ON DELAYS OF
PROJECT. YOU CAN'T EVEN HAVE AN
UP FRONT CONVERSATION ABOUT
THOSE YOU HAVE A BILL
MOVING FORWARD THAT PUTS SOME
PRESSURE ON PEOPLE TO SAY WE'RE
GOING TO DO SOMETHING SO THAT'S
WHY I RESPECTFULLY JOIN IN WITH
THE AUTHORED TROOPS IN TERMS OF
SAYING- I HOPE THAT WE WOULD
ALLOW THIS BILL TO MOVE FORWARD
SO THAT THESE CONVERSATIONS CAN
CONTINUE THANK YOU I'LL TAKE
THAT AS MY CLOTHES. BUT ACTUALLY. MISS GARCIA IS ASKED TO MAKE A
- I FEEL MY- OWN. THANK YOU I- I
WANT TO THINK DR PARK MY TENURE
OF THE HIM WORK I KNOW HE'S
ABOUT COM IN BEING THOUGHT AND
SO I HAVE EVERY FAITH AND THAT
HE WILL I AND MOVE OUT FOR I
THINK IT'S AN THAT MOVED THIS
BILL THIRTEEN YEAR AS LONG AND I
AS THE PUBLIC KEEPS LOOKING AT
IS TO BE RESPONSIVE ID'S LEAD
LINES ENSURE THAT RESPONSIVENESS
WHEN WE GO BACK ON TRACK WITH
THE TRANSCEND THIS DROUGHT- IS
BAD AND IT'S GETTING WORSE AND
WE NEED TO HAVE THE POLITICAL
WILL TO DO WHAT WE DIDN'T DO.
EIGHT YEARS AGO MY COLLEAGUE
POINTED OUT WHEN I WAS HERE FOR
THAT DISCUSSION AS WELL AND SO
I'M HAPPY TO WORK ON THIS BILL
INSISTING CURRENCY OPPOSITION TO
FIND COMPROMISE IN THAT MIDDLE
GROUND DOT AND- NOT JUST MAKE
THIS TO TRY TO MAKE THIS GO AWAY
THING THAT'S GOING TO BE A PATH
THAT IS NOT SUCCESSFUL. THIS
TIME AROUND A LOT OF THIS. THANK
YOU MR GARCIA. WE SO I MR
QUIRK-SILVA OKAY- AND I WANT TO
SEE THAT- I REALLY TO TAKE MY
CALL FOR THEIR ROBUST DISCUSSION
ON THIS I KNOW MISTER QUIRK THIS
GARCIA SAID IS COMMITTED TO
WORKING ON THIS BUT I THINK THAT
ONE OF THE IMPORTANT ROLES OF
THIS LEGISLATURE IS TAKEN OUT OF
MY TIME HERE AND I KNOW IT
STARTED BEFORE I GOT HERE IS OF
OVERSIGHT IS ENSURING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
DEPARTMENTS AND THOSE THAT WE
HAVE RESPONSIBILITY OVER DOING
THE WORK THEY'VE COMMITTED TO
DOING AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL IS ASKING. PLANNING
MISTER BENNETT FIND QUESTIONING
WAS VERY APT YOU KNOW WHEN DO
YOU BELIEVE THEY CAN ACTUALLY DO
WHAT THEY SAID THEY WERE
SUPPOSED TO DO OVER A DECADE AGO
AND THE ANSWER WAS. THERE WAS NO
ANSWER AND SO I THINK IT IS
INCUMBENT UPON US AS THE
LEGISLATURE TO SAY NO TO. THE
TIME IS COME FOR YOU TO DO THE
WORK YOU'VE COMMITTED TO DOING.
AND AS MR CORKER SAID HE'S OPEN
TO ALL SORTS OF WAYS TO ENSURE
THAT HAPPENS BUT- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT WE CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION SO THAT WE DO MAKE
MORE PROGRESS. IN ENSURING A
HEALTHY. ECOSYSTEM FOR. OTH OUR
FISH AND WILDLIFE AND A HEALTHY
FUTURE FOR CALIFORNIA'S WATER-
WHICH IS REALLY IMPERATIVE AT
THIS MOMENT IN TIME AS MANY
COLLEAGUES HAVE. SAID AND I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE HAVE A
MOTION. THANK YOUNG. QUICKLY S.
SECTION FEDERAL PLACE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC.
MATERIALS COMMITTEE FAR QUE HAN
. BARRICADE HAND I DALY NO DOLLY
NOW BENNETT BENNETT I BIGELOW
FRIEDMAN GARCIA GARCIA I KALRA
LEVIN LEVINE AYE. RUBIO AYE
SALAS SMITH THE VALLAPUDUA. THE
APPEAL COULD WHAT NOT VOTING
WARD. IT DOES NOT COLLEAGUES
THAT WILL OPEN THANK CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM THANK YOU
MISTER BLOOM YOU ARE AT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE IF YOU
ONLY KNEW HOW LONG THAT WAS
GONNA TAKE YOU MAY NOT OF THE
SAME POSITION. PASS OVER HERE AB
TWENTY FIVE TWELVE BY MISTER
BLUE WHEN YOU'RE RIGHT I GOT TO
HEAR AN INTERESTING FISCAL. IF
INDEED. THANK FOR THAT OF THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- SAY EVEN BEFORE
THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
RESOLVE ECONOMIC DOWNTURN THERE
WAS AN ENORMOUS FINANCIAL STRAIN
ON MANY SANCTUARY OR RESCUE WILD
ANIMAL FACILITIES IN THE STATE
IS EXPECTED TO ASSUME-RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE CARE AND
RELOCATION OF THE FACILITIES
ANIMALS THAT'S- GOOD. A TO
ADDITIONALLY AS THE FREQUENCY
SCOPE AND BREADTH OF WILDFIRES
INCREASE THROUGH CALIFORNIA MANY
OF THESE FACILITIES HAVE FACED
POTENTIAL EMERGENCY EVACUATIONS
AND ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL
PRESSURES THAT PUT THEM AND
THEIR ANIMALS IN JEOPARDY. FOR
EXAMPLE IN TWENTY NINETEEN A
FACILITY CALLED THE WILDLIFE WAY
STATION IN CELLMARK CALIFORNIA-
WHICH COULD NOT RECOVER
FINANCIALLY FROM THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN CREEK FIRE HAD TO
CLOSE RESULTING IN THE STATE
INCURRING SIGNIFICANT. STRAINS
AND FINANCIAL COSTS FOUR HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY ANIMALS HAD TO BE
CARED FOR AND PLACED THE COST TO
THE STATE IN ASSISTING WITH THIS
FACILITY CLOSURE WAS ENORMOUS.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS SPENT
APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN FACILITY
MAINTENANCE DAILY CARE OF THE
ANIMALS STAFFING PURCHASING OF
FOOD. AND WATER. AB TWENTY FIVE
TWELVE MAKE SEVERAL CHANGES TO
THE FISH AND GAME CODE TO REDUCE
THE BURDEN OF THESE CLOSURES ON
THE DEPARTMENT AND STATE REDUCES
REST OF THE PUBLIC NATIVE
WILDLIFE AND AGRICULTURE CAUSED
BY SOME CAPTIVE WILD ANIMAL
SPECIES. AT ALLOWS THE TO MOVE
MORE QUICKLY TO ENSURE THAT
ANIMALS AT THESE FACILITIES
CONTINUE TO RECEIVE APPROPRIATE
AND NECESSARY CARE. IT DOES THIS
BY MAKING SEVERAL CHANGES TO THE
FISH AND GAME CODE THAT WILL
GIVE CDFW CLEAR AUTHORITY TO
LIMIT OR PROHIBIT ANIMALS AND
THEIR USES. GIVE CDFW THE
ABILITY TO REMEDY VIOLATIONS AND
GETS THE DEPARTMENT FINANCIAL
ASSURANCE BY BEING ABLE TO
ADJUST EXISTING FEES. ALL OF THE
CHANGES WILL BE IMPLEMENTED BY
PUBLIC PROCESS THROUGH THE FISH
AND GAME COMMISSION WITH
STAKEHOLDER AND PUT. WE ARE
ACTIVELY WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND OPPOSITION TO
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS IT'S
GONNA TAKE A LITTLE TIME BUT
WE'RE TRYING TO WORK OUT THE
CONCERNS OF THAT OPPOSITION
HALF. AT THE END OF THE DAY THIS
BILL IS ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
THERE'S A SAFETY NET FOR THESE
FACILITIES AND THAT THE BURDEN
IS NOT SOLELY ON THE STATE.
THANK YOU- THIS BLAIR KRISTIN
GORE WITH THE OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE IS AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AND PROVIDE TECHNICAL
BACKGROUND OUT. OFTEN BY PHONE
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON FILE
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL. OPERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE. WE CAN DO SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE AT THE
SAME TIME. THANK YOU N. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
AB TWENTY FIVE TWELVE. THANK YOU
OF AB TWENTY FIVE TWELVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FIVE
TWELVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE GATHER THE LINE
NUMBER.
THE BILL JUST A FEW MOMENTS. THE. NINE FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JASON BRYANT ON BEHALF OF THE
ZOOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICA AND THE FIVE EASY A
ACCREDITED ZOOS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. Z. A HAS AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON THIS
BILL. AND THE G. A. SHARES THE
AUTHORS GOAL OF ENSURING
FACILITIES ARE FINANCIALLY SOUND
IN CALIFORNIA BUT WE HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE SECTIONS BILL
TO GIVE THE DEPARTMENT EMERGENCY
RULE MAKING AUTHORITY TO
PROHIBIT OR REMOVE SPECIES FROM
ONE OF OUR CREDIT IS. WE'RE ALSO
CONCERNED WITH SECTIONS THAT
GIVE THE DEPARTMENT NEW CF FORTY
AND THE ABILITY TO PLACE A LIEN
ON THE PROPERTY OF A SPECIES
PERMIT HOLDER. WINTER CENTER
BEEN ISSUES THAT NOT CREDIT
FACILITIES FOR THE DEPARTMENT
HAS HAD TO HEAR PARTS TO BE HAD
TO BEAR THE FINANCIAL BURDEN.
WHEN THOSE SOCIETIES BECOME NON
OPERATIONAL. BEFORE TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
DEPARTMENT FOCUSING THE BILL THE
TYPES OF FACILITIES WHICH ARE
SUBJECT TO THE CONCERNS AND WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH. US
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD IT WILL BE JUST BE TAKING
NAMES PHYSICIAN AN ORGANIZATION
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT THE ANDREA
CALDWELL CALLING ON BEHALF OF
SAN DIEGO IS THE WILD. ALLIANCE
AND WE REMAIN COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE DOCTORS OFFICE
AND THE DEPARTMENT PROFESSIONAL
WILDLIFE TO RESOLVE OUR
CONCERNS. BUT AS THE BILL
LANGUAGE DOWN TODAY WHEN THE
PARTS THAT WE NEED TO OPPOSE I'M
NOT AMENDED THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY FIVE TWELVE THANK
YOU ANY OPPOSITION HERE IN THE
ROOM. I DIDN'T FORGET ABOUT YOU
. OKAY. OR IS THERE AB WELCOME
WE DON'T HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
FILE SO WILL. DID THEY. WE HAVE
A LETTER FROM APPARENTLY THAT
THE IS NOT A OF OKAY SO WE'LL
TAKE MINUTES OF COMMENT IF YOU
LIKE OKAY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MAP TO BE OUR THE
CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS WE HAVE
BEEN OPPOSING. AMENDED POSITION
WE REPRESENT WORKERS IN THE FILM
AND TELEVISION INDUSTRY THAT OUR
ANIMAL HANDLERS AND TRAINERS. I
APPRECIATE MR BLOOM'S A
KNOWLEDGE MEANT THAT HE'S GOING
TO YOU KNOW CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH US. I ON A DRESSING THE
CONCERNS WE HAVE I THINK YOU
KNOW WE'RE WORRIED ABOUT. THE
IMPACT OF THE POSSESSION BAND IF
AN ANIMAL. IS LISTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT THAT IS. NECESSITATED
FOR A FILM SCRIPT A COMMERCIAL-
WE WOULD NECESSARILY HAVE TO GO
FILM OUT OF STATE AND YOU KNOW
IT'S BEEN CLEAR FROM THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE THAT. WERE NOT
THE CONCERN OF THE BILL- AND IF
THAT'S THE CASE YOU KNOW WE
WOULD URGE THEM. TOWARDS A SET
OF AMENDMENTS THAT WE SHARE WITH
THE AUTHOR THAT WOULD- YOU WOULD
REALLY CLARIFY THAT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU FOR. I'M
EIGHT. FIFTY FIVE GOOD MORNING.
THAT PEOPLE COMING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA'S. OF ZOOS IN A-
SO TRADE ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIANS REPRESENTS THE
STATE'S. LARGEST ACCREDITED.
FACILITIES I'M WE SUPPORT THE
AUTHOR'S INTENTION WE DON'T WANT
ANYMORE WILDLIFE WEIGH STATIONS
EITHER UNFORTUNATELY THE WAY THE
BILL IS DRAFTED. IT ENCAPSULATED
COVERS A WHOLE LOT MORE THAN
THAT. WE HAVE- ABOUT THE BILL WE
CIRCULATED A LETTER TO THE
COMMITTEE AND TO THE MEMBERS-
HAVE EVERY CONFIDENCE THAT WILL
BE ABLE TO WORK THIS OUT WITH.
WITH THE AUTHOR IN THE
DEPARTMENT BUT- WILL HAVE TO
REGISTER OUR CONCERNS IN CASE WE
DO NEED TO OPPOSE THE BILL AT
SOME POINT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S ALL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
YES MR LEVINE. YEAH I THINK YOU
FOR THE BILL MISTER BLUE I WANT
TO JUST. THE ANALYSIS WHICH
CALLED OUT THE COST OF THE STATE
WHICH I THINK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND WHY WHY
ARE WE DOING THIS BILL- YOU KNOW
COSTS ARE BEING PUT ON TO US BUT
WHAT WAS INTERESTING TO ME- WAS
ALSO- THE QUESTION OF. HOW DO WE
CARE FOR THESE ANIMALS WHEN THEY
COME INTO OUR CUSTODY AND- SO I
KNOW THAT YOU HAVE A WITNESS-
ON. THE PHONE THAT THAT IS
AVAILABLE. DO WE- CARE FOR THEM
AND STATE FACILITIES ARE THERE
OTHER ISSUES OR PLACES WHERE WE
THEN. PUT THEM AND THEN COVER
THAT THOSE EXPERT YOU KNOW
BOARDING COSTS- I'M JUST CURIOUS
HOW THE STATE DOES THAT. THAT'S
QUESTION FOR CHRIS GORY YET.
MISTER COREY ARE YOU ON THE LINE
CANCER THIS LIVING QUESTION. YET
YEAH THANK YOU HI KRISTIN GLORY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE- SO IN THIS INSTANCE
WHEN THE DEPARTMENT- HAD TO TAKE
OVER THE WILDLIFE WAY STATION
THE ANIMALS ACTUALLY STAYED ON
SITE AND WE BROUGHT IN SUPPORT-
TO- MET WITH THE ANIMALS
INCLUDING TRUCKING IN WATER
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO. WATER ON
SITE AND- AS ANIMAL- AS WE FOUND
LOCATION TO ROUTE TO EVERY FOUND
OPTIONS TO RELOCATE THE ANIMALS
WE WITH HAVE TO GO INSPECT THOSE
. MAKE SURE THAT THEY THEY MEET
THE STANDARDS BEFORE THE ANIMAL
COULD BE TRANSFERRED- BUT THAT
PROCESS THAT TIME OVER THE LAST
IT'S BEEN ALMOST THREE YEARS
THAT THAT'S BEEN GOING ON- ALL
OF THE ANIMALS HAVE BEEN
RELOCATED TO NEW FACILITIES. IN
THE STATE OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA-
THERE ARE EIGHTEEN CHIMPANZEES
THAT ARE STILL ON SITE WE HOW
THE- POTENTIALLY NEW HOME FOR
ALL OF THEM- BUT THEY'RE GOING
THROUGH THAT REVIEW PROCESS
RIGHT NOW AND IT'S OUR GOAL THAT
BY THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
THEY WILL. BE A THEIR. AND AS A
FOLLOW UP- THAT THE STATE HAS
NO- ESSENTIALLY NOT NOT SEIZING
THAT PROPERTY BUT THAT KIND OF
TAKING MANAGEMENT RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THAT PROPERTY- AS JUST A BUT
TELL ME HOW THAT WORKS. CHRIS.
SO THE STATE WELL WE CAME IN-
WITH THE OPENNESS OF WILDLIFE
WAY STATION IN THEIR EXISTING
STAFF AND THEY ALLOW THAT- ON
THE PROPERTY EIGHT- THAT WAS
BECAUSE OF THAT MUTUAL
AGREEMENT- THAT THEY ALLOWED
THAT WE ALSO HAVE A MAJORITY OF
THEIR- ON STAFF THAT WERE
FAMILIAR WITH THE ANIMALS TO
HELP WITH THAT THAT'S- A BIT I
THINK THAT THAT IS UNIQUE TO
THAT SITUATION- AND I'M NOT SURE
HOW IT WOULD PLAY OUT IN A
DIFFERENT ONE. OKAY THANK YOU.
YOU MISTER LEVINE ANY OTHER. OR
COMMENTS. OKAY WHEN I KNOW I'M
OUT I REALLY APPRECIATE EXACTLY
LEVINE POINTED OUT WHICH IS OUR
FOCUS ON THE STATE HAVING TO
BEAR THE BURDEN OF THESE
FACILITIES- NOT PROPERLY CARING
FOR BEING ABLE TO CARE FOR THESE
ANIMALS- BUT IF YOU WOULD IN
YOUR CLOTHES ADDRESS ON THE
COMMENTS BY ON THE OPPOSITION
REGARDING THE IMPACTS TO THE
ECONOMIC ENGINE IN YOUR
COMMUNITY. BY WHAT I KNOW IT'S
I'M SURE CONSERVE YOURSELF WITH
THAT. YOU'RE A THANK YOU ANNA
CHAIR THE LAST THING I WANT TO
SEE- AS A CO AUTHOR OF EVERY
ITERATION OF THE FILM TAX
CREDIT. AND- MY OFFICE WORKED
VERY HARD TO IMPROVE THE
LANGUAGE AND ALL THOSE BILLS-
LAST THING I WANT TO SEE IS- OF
THE FILM INDUSTRY OR ANY
INDUSTRY- OF LEAVE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- SO WE'RE COMMITTED
TO. WORKING HARD TO WORK OUT
THESE ISSUES- I THINK THEY ARE
ALL READ. BUT IT IS GOING TO
TAKE SOME TIME THESE ARE THORNY
ISSUES WE DO WANT TO PROVIDE.
PROTECTION OF FOR THESE ANIMALS-
THROUGH THE- DEPARTMENT- THROUGH
THE DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS AND WE
THINK IT'S ONLY RIGHT. THAT-
THE- OF FACILITIES. SHARE SOME
OF THE COSTS IT'S ALMOST IN THE
NATURE OF AN INSURANCE POLICY-
BUT WE UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS
OF FOR. THE TEAMSTERS AND OTHERS
IN PARTICULAR WHAT CARD TO
ADDRESS IT. THANK YOU DO WE HAVE
A MOTION ON THIS BILL. FACT
FACTS. FEBRUARY CALDERON. THE
MOTION IS THE PAST JUDITH.
BARRICADE HAN I THERE QUE HAN I
DOLLAR. DALI I BENNETT THE WAY
THE SALLY. RIGHT NOW NO. NO YES
THE NO. BENNETT I BENNETT I BIG
FRIEDMAN FREED AYE GARCIA. I
YEAH I KALRA LEVINE HI LEVINE I
MURATSUCHI MEHR SIXTY WENT. WHEN
NOT VOTER. RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS
SMITH BE APPROVED WHAT THE
VALLAPUDUA I WARD. THANK YOU
MISTER BLOOM AND THANK YOU MR
GARCIA FOR ALLOWING THIS REFER
THEM TO JUMP THE LINE. WE WILL
NOW TAKE AT. MR GARCIA'S AB.
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SEVEN. GOOD
MORNING I'M OUT OF CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES. IT WAS A- THE- TODAY
I'M PRESENTING- BEFORE YOU AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SEVEN OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL BONDING TO INVEST
SEVEN POINT FOUR THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN ORDER TO RESPOND TO
THE WIDE ARRAY OF CLIMATE CHANGE
IMPACTS IN OUR STATE I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE WORK OF YOUR
COMMITTEE TEAM WHO HAS DONE AN
EXCELLENT JOB IN THE ANALYSIS-
THE ANALYSIS GIVES A VERY CLEAR
DEPICTION OF HOW THESE DOLLARS
WOULD BE DISTRIBUTED. I COULD GO
DOWN THE LIST- BUT YOU'LL HAVE
YOUR ANALYSIS IN FRONT OF YOU I
DO WANT TO JUST BRING TO
ATTENTION THAT THERE IS- A
RECOGNITION THAT- STATE
CALIFORNIA'S EXPERIENCING A ON
PRESIDENT SURPLUS AND THAT THERE
COULD BE BE INVEST IN THIS
PARTICULAR AREA COMING FROM THAT
SURPLUS AND SO WE RECOGNIZE-
THAT THOSE DISCUSSIONS ARE
ONGOING. I LIKE TO JUST SAY THAT
THIS- PROPOSAL ALLOWS FOR
LEGISLATORS LIKE YOURSELF
ANOTHER MEMBERS OF OTHER
COMMITTEES TO BE PART OF THE
PROCESS AND HAVE INPUT IN WHAT
THE STRUCTURE OF THOSE
INVESTMENTS COULD POTENTIALLY
LOOK LIKE- ONE WOULD SAY FILE WE
HAVE A SURPLUS WHY WOULD WE PUT
THIS THE VOTERS AVERAGE POINT TO
THE LAST- ASSESSMENT DONE A
CALIFORNIA ASSESSMENT THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THAT HIGHLIGHTS OVER A
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS OF IT
IMPACT. AS A RESULT OF PLAN
CHANGE AND SO FOR THOSE AND BE
YOU TODAY PROPOSING THIS UP BOB
RUPEES LEGISLATION THAT WOULD GO
BEFORE THE VOTERS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU MR GARCIA AND I
SEE WE DON'T HAVE ANY WITNESSES
LISTED IN SUPPORT AND I DON'T
PULL BACK TO SOMEONE. IN THE
ROOM. AB WE'VE ANY SUPPORT IN
THE ROOM. COME ON UP. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS MATT BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE PARADISE
IRRIGATION DISTRICT AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THAT CHAIR
MEMBERS DOUG HOUSTON
REPRESENTING EAST BAY REGIONAL
PARK DISTRICTS IN NUMBER COUNTY
PARKS WORSHIP CONSERVATION
AUTHORITY THE CALIFORNIA PARK
AND RECREATION SOCIETY ALL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND. HELLO
ABIGAIL MILE REPRESENTING MID
PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT ON THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS FOUNDATION ALSO SUPPORT.
ZERO NOBODY ELSE HERE IN THE
ROOM SO WE'LL GO TO THE FRONT
LINES ANYONE IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE LINES. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SEVEN%
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF. AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SEVEN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO.
NINE FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEDICARE
AND MEMBERS MARK SMITH ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS CONTINUED
PERSISTENCE I'M TRYING TO MOVE A
BOND FOR. THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
KIM ELFINO ON THE BEHALF OF
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE AND ON THE
LAND TRUST AND THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY DEPORTED AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SEVEN
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM. I HAD MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MIKE WEST ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL WERE
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION WE SHARED OUR AMENDMENT
TO THE AUTHOR AND LOOK FORWARD
TO GETTING TOGETHER WITH HIM AND
A STAFF THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE ROOM. ANY
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SEVEN. EIGHT
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM.
MEMBERS YES PLEASE TELLING.
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR I KNOW
THAT THERE'S SOME VERY IMPORTANT
INVESTMENTS PROPOSED IN THIS
BOND AND JUST WHAT YOU SPOKE IN
YOUR OPENING ABOUT THE FACT THAT
WE HAVE SUCH AS WE HAVE A
SURPLUS AND I'D LIKE TO SEE
THESE INVESTMENTS BE MADE BUT
NOT THROUGH A BOND PROCESS SO I
DO SUPPORT YOUR EFFORTS- I'D
LIKE TO SEE MORE WATER STORAGE
WE'VE HAD THAT UNITED HAD THAT
DSCUSSION ABOUT THE WATER BOND
WHICH WAS BACK IN. TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN AND WE- OBVIOUSLY HAVE
THE DISCUSSION HERE OF- WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES. IN REGARDS TO MAKING
SURE ACCOUNTABILITY IS HAPPENING
THAT THOSE PROJECTS WERE MADE
INTENDED FOR THE BOUGHT WATER
BOND. ALSO HAPPENED SO- I'M NOT
ABOUT TO SUPPORT THIS TODAY BUT
I EIGHT I WOULD LIKE TO
HOPEFULLY WE'LL SEE THESE IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS. YEAH ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM THE STAFF. LOOKS
LIKE KNOWS. MISTER GARCIA WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE NOT. YOU KNOW
THOSE COMMENTS ARE WELL TAKEN
AND AGAIN THAT WE ARE VERY
COGNISANT OF. THE POSSIBILITIES
OF THESE INVESTMENTS- COMING.
OUT FROM. THE BUDGET BUT BUT
I'LL JUST AGAIN YOU KNOW
REITERATE THE- SIGNIFICANT-
AMOUNT OF INVESTMENTS AT THAT
THAT WE- WILL REQUIRE- TO
PROTECT THAT BOTH PUBLIC HEALTH-
PUBLIC PROPERTY. AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY THE ECONOMY OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THAT AS I
MENTIONED THE ASSESSMENT THAT
POINTS OUT TO A HUNDRED. MILLION
DOLLAR AND- WITH THE- LEVEL OF
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'VE MADE. AB
CURRENTLY SO WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THEY YOU MR GARCIA I WANT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ONGOING EFFORT IN
THIS I KNOW THIS IS THE
BEGINNING OF THIS DISCUSSION-
FROM YOU AND AT I KNOW WE HAD A
CONVERSATION RECENTLY AT THE BAY
AREA CAUCUS WITH YOUR CO AUTHOR
MR MULLIN ABOUT THE PORT TO THE
STAR KANEMI. IN THE VERY AS WELL
SO I APPRECIATE THIS EFFORT DO
WE HAVE A MOTION. SECOND THANKS
FOR THE COLOR. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE OUR QUE HAN HI
BARRICADE HAND AYE DOLLY DOLLY
NO BENNETT BIGELOW FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA. KALRA LEVIN
LEVINE AYE MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI
I WON. WHEN NOT VOTING RUBIO
RUBIO AYE SALAS SMITH SMITH NO
THE APPROVED WHAT THE VALLAPUDUA
FIVE WARD. IT DOES NOT CALL
THANK YOU. YEAH YEAH.
OKAY. HELLO HELLO MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I WANT TO- THIS IS
AB TWENTY SIX TEN. OKAY. GREAT
THANK YOU OF SO THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR WITH FIRST OF ALL WITH
REGARD TO THE ANALYSIS I ACCEPT
THE FOR COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
LISTED ON PAGE FIVE OF THE
ANALYSIS I'M PLATE PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
FOUR A BILL TO REQUIRE STATE
AGENCIES TO IMPLEMENT WILDLIFE
CROSSINGS AND IDENTIFIED
CONNECTIVITY'S AREAS FOR NEW
PROJECTS AND TO ADDRESS EXISTING
BARRIERS IDENTIFIED AS PROJECTS
HIGHWAYS OR MAJOR BECAUSE OF
WILDFIRE DEATH IN CALIFORNIA BUT
THEY'RE NOT JUST DANGEROUS AND
DEADLY FOR ANIMALS AND A LARGE
ANIMAL LIKE A DEER OR A POEM A
CROSSING A HIGHWAY CAN ALSO LEAD
TO A TERRIBLE. TRAFFIC ACCIDENT
AND LEAD TO HUMAN DEATH IN
ADDITION WILDLIFE THAT'S
ISOLATED IN SOME OF OUR AREAS
BECAUSE OF THIS LARGE PIECES OF
INFRASTRUCTURE CAN LEAD TO
INTERBREEDING ALL KINDS OF
HEALTH PROBLEMS FOR THOSE
ANIMALS AND A LOT OF STRESSORS-
AND NOW IN TERMS OF THE- PROBLEM
WITH PUBLIC SAFETY TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN AND TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
THERE WERE OVER FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND COLLISIONS WITH LARGE
WILDLIFE IN OUR HIGHWAYS- AS
REPORTED BY CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL ON AVERAGE FIVE PEOPLE
ARE KILLED AND OVER TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY PEOPLE WERE INJURED IN
CALIFORNIA REPORTED WILDLIFE
VEHICLE COLLISIONS EACH EAR.
THE ROAD CALLED YOU CENTER AT UC
DAVIS IS ESTIMATED THE TOTAL
COST OF REPORTED COLLISIONS
BETWEEN THIS WILDLIFE AND THIS
OF THOSE ARE LARGE ANIMALS LIKE
MULE DEER BEARS AND MOUNTAIN
LIONS AND VEHICLES TO BE AT
LEAST ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
DAMAGE FROM TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
TO TWO THOUSAND TWENTY SO THAT'S
A BIG CHUNK OF CHANGE- NOT TO
MENTION OF COURSE THE HUMAN AND
WILDLIFE COST AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY FOUR REQUIRES CALTRANS AND
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WILDLIFE TO
IDENTIFY AREAS WITH HIGH RATES
OF WILDFIRE VEHICLE COLLISIONS
OVER TARGETING THIS ON AREAS
WHERE IT MAKES THE MOST SENSE.
AND TO IMPLEMENT TEN PRIOR PER
PER YEAR TO IMPROVE CONNECTIVITY
WITH PASSAGE FEATURES LIKE
OVERPASSES UNDERPASSES AND
DIAGONAL FENCING TO HELP PREVENT
THAT THOSE COLLISIONS. BOTH
STATE AND FEDERAL FOR
TRANSPORTATION FUNDS ARE
AVAILABLE FOR THIS TYPES OF
PROTECTIONS. WILDLIFE CROSSINGS
CAN IMPROVE WILDLIFE MOVEMENT
WHILE REDUCING WILDLIFE VEHICLE
COLLISIONS BY UP 298% WHEN
THEY'RE IMPLEMENTED. SO WHAT
BETTER PLANNING AND BETTER
INFRASTRUCTURE WE CAN PROTECT
BOTH PEOPLE AND WILDLIFE IN
PROPERTY. TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY THREE FORTY FOUR
TODAY OR TIFFANY YAP FOR THE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY.
AND WINSTON VICKERS THE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA MOUNTAIN LION
PROJECT AT UC DAVIS AS WILDLIFE
HEALTH CENTER AND I REQUEST
FULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. A STEP ME. IT IS THE DOCTOR
VICKERS- EXPERTS THINK GONNA BE. OPERATE DO WE HAVE THE WITNESS
ON THE LINE. AND MAY I HAVE YOU
STATE THE NAME AGAIN PLEASE-
WINSTON BAKER. YES THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
. COMMITTEE FOR ME TO COMMENT-
AS THE INTRODUCTION SET UP
WINSTON VICKERS I'M WILDLIFE
RESEARCH VETERINARIAN WITH UC
DAVIS WILDLIFE HEALTH CENTER I'M
SPEAKING TODAY AS A CITIZEN IS A
KNOWLEDGEABLE SCIENTISTS NOT AS
A REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
INSTITUTION I'VE STUDIED WHILE
AFTER TWENTY YEARS FOR THE
SPECIAL FOCUS ON MOUNTAIN LIONS
AND HAVE BEEN INVOLVED WITH A
NUMBER OF HIGHWAY CROSSING AND
ROAD KILL REDUCTION PROJECT OVER
THAT TIME I PERSONALLY RETRIEVE
MANY ABOUT LANCE FROM ROW JOHN.
AFTER THEY WERE KILLED IN
COLLISIONS IT ALSO MAY HAVE BEEN
DANGER CAIMANS AND ROAD
MORTALITIES OF THE NUMBER ONE
CAUSE OF DEATH FOR MEN CHEN OUR
STUDY AREA IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN FACT THIS TWO DAYS
AGO MY BIOLOGIST PICKED UP A
LARGE ADULT MALE WAS KILLED ON
THE SIXTY FREEWAY BUT MANY
FREEWAYS SUCH A BARRIER THAT
PREVENTED EVEN ATTEMPT TO CROSS
AND AS A RESULT SOME OUTLINED
POPULATION IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ARE AT RISK OF
INBREEDING DEPRESSION AND
POSSIBLY AN EXTINCTION VORTEX.
WELL I PASSAGE FEATURE ARE
NECESSARY TO ALLEVIATE THIS
PROBLEM FROM OUTLINES AND OTHER
WILDLIFE IN OTHER AREAS AS WELL
BUT TO BE EFFECTIVE OTHER
CONSIDERATION SHOULD BE KEPT IN
MIND IN ORDER TO ENSURE FUNCTION
OF ANY CROSSING RESEARCH IS
USUALLY NEEDED BEFORE
ENGINEERING STARTED IN ORDER TO
DETERMINE THAT ANSWERS A KEY
QUESTIONS FUNDING FOR SUCH
RESEARCH OFTEN HAS TO COME
SEPARATELY FROM OUTSIDE SOURCES
FOLLOWING CROSSING STRUCTURE
DESIGN AND IMPLEMENTATION
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE CERTAINLY
EXPERIENCED WHEN WORKING WITH
CROSSING DESIGN. QUESTIONS OFTEN
INCLUDE DEFINING THE SPECIES ARE
MOST CONCERNED WHETHER TRAVEL
INTERSECTS THE HIGHWAY WHETHER
POTENTIAL CROSSING LOCATIONS ARE
BOUNDED BY CONSERVE LANDS OR
WHETHER MORE CONSERVATION OF
LAND IS NEEDED DEFINING WHAT
TYPE OF STRUCTURES BACK PUT
PARTICULARS OF CONCERN FINDING
WHAT OTHER MEASURES ARE NEEDED
SUCH AS CONTROL TRESPASSED NOISE
AND LIGHT REDUCTION AT CENTER
AND DEFINING POTENTIAL FUTURE.
THREATS TO CROSSING THE CATION
INTACT. FINALLY HOW WILL UP
ASSESSMENT OF THE TRACK. BY
CONDUCT. AND PERHAPS. I'D LIKE
TO URGE THE COMMITTEE KEEP ALL
THESE DAYS IN MY WHEN CAN. THE
ON THIS ISSUE. RELATING TO
WILDLIFE AND ROW CROSSINGS THANK
. THANK YOU. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MY
NAME'S TIFFANY UP SENIOR
SCIENTIST AT THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TODAY. LET'S CENTERS PLEASE THE
SPA THE FAVOR OF THE WHILE
PROTECTION ACT. AND WE
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN KALRA FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA. THIS
BILL IS INCREDIBLY TIMELY
CALIFORNIA'S RICH BIODIVERSITY
IS BEING DECIMATED BY ROADS AND
LACK OF WHILE THE CONNECTIVITY.
CALTRANS HAS A KNOWLEDGE OF THIS
ISSUE. THE F. W. IS READY AND
ABLE TO HELP INTEGRATE
CONNECTIVITY INTO TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS. AND THERE'S A PUBLIC
AWAKENING OF THE GREAT BENEFITS
OF IMPROVE CONNECTIVITY ON OUR
ROADS. ISOLATED PUMA POPULATIONS
COULD DISAPPEAR IN OUR LIFETIMES
DESERT TORTOISE NUMBERS ARE
DWINDLING. NEWTS ARE BEING
KILLED BY THE THOUSANDS EVERY
YEAR. BIRDS BUTTERFLIES BEAR
LIZARDS. ALL OF OUR WILD
NEIGHBORS ARE A GREAT RISK. AND
SO ARE PEOPLE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN MENTIONED THAT THERE
WERE ABOUT FORTY FOUR THOUSAND
REPORTED COLLISIONS WITH LARGE
MAMMALS. FROM TWENTY SIXTEEN TO
TWENTY TWENTY ESTIMATED TO COST
CALIFORNIANS MORE THAN ONE
BILLION DOLLARS. BUT THIS ISN'T
EVEN THE FULL PICTURE. THIRTY
SUGGEST THE NUMBERS COULD BE
THREE TO EIGHT POINT FIVE TIMES
HIGHER. PEOPLE DON'T ALWAYS
REPORT SUCH COLLUSION. OR ADAM
SURVIVED COLLISION TO DIE FROM
THEIR INJURIES AWAY FROM THE
ROAD. FOR EXAMPLE. ONE OF FOR A
YOUNG MALE PUMA. WAS KILLED IN A
HIT AND RUN ON PCH. N. O. R.
NINETY THREE THE ORGAN WILL OF
THAT BUDGET AS FAR SOUTH AS
VENTURA. WAS FOUND DEAD ON A
DIRT TRAIL NEAR I. FIVE AFTER
BEING HIT BY A VEHICLE. THESE
DOES ARE. SPECIFICS ARE
PREVENTABLE. ECOSYSTEM COLLAPSE
IS PREVENTABLE. IN AREAS WHERE
OTHER STATES HAVE INSTALLED WELL
PLANNED WILDLIFE CROSSINGS.
VEHICLE WILDLIFE COLLISIONS HAVE
BEEN BUTTE HAVE BEEN REDUCED BY
UP TO NINETY EIGHT PERCENT. WELL
FACILITATING WILDLIFE MOVEMENT.
NOW'S THE TIME TO COMMIT AT THE
STATE TO BUILD MY LIFE CONNECTED
INTO OUR TRANSFER.
INFRASTRUCTURE AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY FOUR WOULD BE A BIG STEP
TOWARDS MAKING BOTH PEOPLE AND
WILDLIFE SAFER WE ASKED THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THIS EFFORT
AND MOVED AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
FOUR FORWARD TODAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SIR ANYONE ELSE IN
THE ROOM IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR JENNIFER
HEARING ON BEHALF OF THE NOT
MIND AND SAN DIEGO MEET SUPPORT. I'LL BE A MILE ONCE AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE MID PENDANTS
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT ON
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
OPERATOR IT OPEN UP THE LINE
PLEASE FOR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. NINE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR KIM DELFINO
ON BEHALF OF DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE THE NORMAL LAND TRUST
AND THE PACIFIC FOREST TRUST IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
NINE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING AND WHILE YOU'RE ON THE
HUNT CARE CLUB CALIFORNIA IS
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
FOUR THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE NINE FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
A CLEAR AFRICA ON BEHALF OF THE
PLANNING CONSERVATION LEAGUE AT
THE PORT OF EIGHTY TWENTY THREE
FORTY FOUR THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT
WHILE WE GATHER THE LINE NUMBER. ONE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
COCKSURE NEWMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
PENINSULA OPEN SPACE TRUST THE
MOJAVE DESERT LAND TRUST AND THE
LEVEL OF CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT
. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY FOUR. THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM TODAY
IN OPPOSITION. OPERATOR CAN YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY THREE FORTY FOUR.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
. WE HAVE NO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY FOUR. IN Q. AND A OPEN UP
TO MEMBERS WITH ANY QUESTIONS.
MISTER SMITH THANK YOU MADAM
VICE CHAIR BY THE CHAIR RIGHT
NOW BUT ANYWAY IT IT'S TEN
WILDLIFE OF CONNECTIVITY
PROJECTS IS THE FUNDING GOING TO
COME OUT OF CALTRANS WEARS A
FUNNY GOING TO GO FOR AND WHAT
IS THE COST OF ONE OF THE USE
AND WE CAN DO THE MULTIPLICATION
AT TEN PER YEAR. SURE THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION- THERE IS BOTH
STATE AND FEDERAL MONEY THAT'S
ALREADY ALLOCATED TO A LOT OF
THIS WORK- AND YES SOME OF IT
WILL COME FROM CALTRANS THERE'S
OTHER SOURCES OF FUNDING THROUGH
DIFFERENT- VARIOUS
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING POTS SOME
SOME OF THE FEDERAL
TRANSPORTATION MONEY AND THE
COST REALLY DEPENDS ON WHAT THE
PROJECT IS YOU KNOW SOME OF
THESE OBVIOUSLY CAN BE EXPENSIVE
ALESSO IF IT'S PART OF A PROJECT
THAT'S BEING INSTALLED FOR
INSTANCE A NEW PROJECT- PART OF
UP FOR YOU KNOW SOMETHING
THAT'S- MAJOR WORK THAT'S BEEN
DONE ON A FREEWAY- AND- IT CAN
BE MORE MINOR IF IT INVOLVES
FENCING A CHANNELING UNDERPASSES
TEND TO BE LESS EXPENSIVE THAN
OVER PASSES FOR INSTANCE SO IT
REALLY. IS A CASE BY CASE- KIND
OF A QUESTION BUT AGAIN WHEN YOU
LOOK AT WHAT THE COST OF THESE
ACCIDENTS ARE- YOU SEE THAT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR PUBLIC SAFETY AS
WELL. SO THERE IS NOT A- SO.
RIGHT NOW OF. BUT THEY'RE STILL
PARTS CONTROL WELL THERE'S NOT
ONE SOURCE OF FUNDING JUST FOR
THIS. OUR TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
COMES FROM VARIOUS POTS THAT
ALWAYS PUT TOGETHER FROM LOCAL
FUNDING FROM CALTRANS. FEDERAL
STATE DEPENDING ON THE PROJECT.
SO IT JUST KIND OF FLOWS TO THE
FORMULA THAT WE USE NOW FOR
HIGH- TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
THANK YOU.
YEAH OKAY COMMITTEE PLEASE OF
THE RED PROMOTION IT MEXICAN
THANK YOU OKAY HAVE A LOOK AT IT. THE MOTION IS THE PAST TO
PROBE. TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
BARRICADE HANNAH BARRICADE HAND
I DOLLY NO DALI NOW BENNETT.
BENNETT I BIGELOW FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA KALRA LEVINE
. LEVINE I'M RESEARCHING
MURATSUCHI I KNOW WHEN. NO NOT
VOTING RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS
SMITH. SMITH NO THE APPROVED
WHAT THE APPROVED WHAT I WARD.
OKAY.
MISS FRIEDMAN REMOVING A TWENTY
SIX TENNIS HERE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR HARD WORK AND TIME IN THIS
BILL AB TWENTY SIX TEN CREATES A
GRANT PROGRAM UNDER THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD TO SUPPORT
ECOLOGICALLY SENSITIVE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT PROJECTS
THESE PROJECTS TO MITIGATE FIRE
RISK BY REDUCING WILDFIRE FUEL
LOADS IN A MANNER THAT MAINTAINS
BIODIVERSITY AND PRESERVE
CALIFORNIA'S NAY PLANT SPECIES
THE GRANDPA ALSO SUPPORT
AGENCIES RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICTS. NONPROFITS AND OTHER
LOCAL ENTITIES IN PROVIDING
WORKFORCE CAPACITY TO THESE PER
IN TO HELP CALIFORNIA REACH BOTH
FEEL WE'RE NOT IN ITS
BIODIVERSITY GOALS TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT THIS AFTERNOON AS DOUG
JOHNSON EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA BASED A PLANT CAL
. AND CODY CIFUENTES WINTERSTEEN
RESOURCE MADE SPECIALIST WITH
THE BIMBILLA REGIONAL- OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
MISS FRIEDMAN WE HAVE CO.
CIFUENTES AND JOHN HOW BY PHONE
OPERATOR. AND THE LINES ARE OPEN
THANK YOU. MISTER HOW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO AGAIN. CRITICS THE
COUNTRY'S WINTER IS ON THE LINE
. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS KIRTI KEY
POINTS OF WINTER AND I AM
LOOKING- READ THANKS SPECIAL AT
THE MINUTE WILL RETURN OPEN
DISTRICT. AND THE PUBLIC MANAGER
WILL MAKE NEARLY EIGHT WHILE IN
FIRE REPELLENCY PROGRAM.
BIODIVERSE HOTSPOT WHICH ARE
AREAS THAT ARE RICH WHITE AND
HIGH RISK OF DESTRUCTION MAKE UP
ABOUT TWO POINT 3% THE FIRST
PLAN SERVICE. SECOND HAND 44% OF
THE WORLD'S PLAN THE 35% OF THE
LAND VERTEBRATE. CALIFORNIA JUST
. OF THE THIRTY FILED. BY OLD.
HOTSPOT IN THE WORLD. IMPLIED
OVER SIXTY FIVE ACRES OF
ACQUIRED PROTECTED LANDS BASED
ON THE STEPS OF COMMITMENT BUT-
AND IS ONE THE LARGEST REGIONAL
OPEN SPACE DISTRICT IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE PROUD TO
SPONSOR THE EIGHTY TWENTY SIX
TAX. VETERANS COMMITMENT TO
PRESERVING OPEN SPACES UP THE
HEART OF OUR MISSION BUT NOT
ONLY SUPPORTING FOUND MANAGEMENT
ACTIVITIES THAT PROTECT AND
RESTORE THE NATURAL ENVIRONMENT.
BUT ALSO. INSPIRE PUBLIC AND
PARTNERS TO PRO ACTIVE ACTION.
ONE OF THE VITAL ACTIVITIES THAT
WE SUPPORT OUR OWN ACTIVITY AND
BY IMPLEMENTING OUR PARTNERS IT
ECOLOGICALLY SENSITIVE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT. WHICH
FOCUSES ON MAINTAINING AND
IMPROVING BIODIVERSITY AND
ECOLOGICAL HEALTH ACROSS
LANDSCAPE BY LIMITING THE SPREAD
OF INVASIVE SPECIES. WHILE
REDUCING. THE RISK OF WILDFIRES
. ADDITIONALLY WELL IF YOU'LL BE
THAT SUCH AS MATHEMATICS MAKING
MOWING PRETEXT CAN GROW FOR SO
TREATED. ALL CAUSING FIFTY FEET
ABOUT BACK RAP AND ROBUSTLY.
ULTIMATELY FUEL LOADS MAKING IT
MORE FOR NEED SPECIES THE. FOR
CORRECTLY UNDER MY THE STATE
SALAS CONCORD. AND BY THE GOAL
INDISCRIMINATELY REMOVING
PLANTLIFE WITHOUT. BECAUSE THE
FROM HELL LOLICON. FOR THE
PRESIDENT OF NEED A PLANT
SPECIES. HOWEVER HE CENTER
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT PRACTICES
SUPPORTED BY AB TWENTY SIX TEN
CAN IMPROVE LONG TERM BY OUR
RISK REDUCTION WHILE BOLSTERING
NATIVE BIODIVERSITY IN TREATED
AREAS. WITH THE ONGOING THREAT
OF WILDFIRES ACROSS THE STATE
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE SUPPORT
FUEL REDUCTION PROJECTS BEYOND
THOSE CARRIED OUT BY THE STATE.
THIS PROGRAM WITH SUPPORT
SMALLER ENTITIES ENSURING OUT
FUEL REDUCTION EFFORT TO PROTECT
ECOLOGICAL HEALTH AND COMPLEMENT
THE FUEL REDUCTION WORK THAT IS
ALREADY UNDERWAY AT THE STATE
LEVEL. FOR THESE REASONS BIG ASK
YOUR I BOTH ON PAGE TWENTY SIX
TEN THANK YOU FOR YOUR KIND OF.
THAT THANK YOU MISTER HOW ON THE
FOR. NOT AT THIS TIME OKAY HI IS
THERE ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL AB TWENTY SIX TEN IN
THE ROOM. NOT SURE IF YOU CAN
HEAR ME- THIS IS DOUG JOHNSON ON
ON THE PHONE. AT THE WHITE HOUSE
THIS WITNESS YES THIS IS JOHN
HOW. NOT MR JOHNSON MR JANET
JOHNSON OUT OKAY. THIS ON ME
OKAY AHEAD MR JOHNSON. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN AUDIBLE CHAIR BAUER K.
HAND AND MEMBERS- THIS IS DOUG
JOHNSON I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE NONPROFIT
CALIFORNIA INVASIVE PLANT
COUNCIL. OUR MISSION IS TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENT
AND ECONOMY FROM INVASIVE
PLANTS. ARE ACTIVE MEMBERSHIP
INCLUDES PUBLIC AND PRIVATE LAND
MANAGERS ECOLOGICAL RESEARCHERS
AND CONSULTANTS PLANNERS
VOLUNTEER STEWARDS AND CONCERNED
CITIZENS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
GALATEA IS A CO SPONSOR OF AB
TWENTY SIX TEN AND I'M HONORED
TO BE HERE TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION. AB
TWENTY SIX TEN. NEW APPROACHES
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT FOR FUEL
REDUCTION IN CALIFORNIA. AS WE
ALL KNOW OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS OUR STATE IT BEEN SUBJECT
TO EVERY. WHILE AND THE LOS
ANGELES REGION LIKE OTHER
REGIONS ACROSS THE STATE IT'S
ALL TOO FAMILIAR WITH THEIR
IMPACT. IN RESPONSE STATE AND
ESTABLISHED MOPTI PEOPLE
REDUCTION GOAL TO ADDRESS
VEGETATION OVERGROWTH AND TO
LIMIT WILD WILD LAND FIRE RISK.
HOWEVER WITH THE PACE AND SCALE
OF WORK NEEDED TO REACH THESE
REDUCTION GOALS. FOR HELP AND
THEN MANAGEMENT AGENCIES DO NOT
NECESSARILY CONSIDER THE LONG
TERM ECOLOGICAL CONSEQUENCES.
BUT TECHNIQUES USED FOR LARGE
SCALE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT.
COMMONLY USED TECHNIQUES CAN
SPREAD INVASIVE PLANT AND DAMAGE
NATIVE VEGETATION. THIS
ALTERNATELY LEADS TO MORE DENSE
VEGETATION AND HEIGHTENED FIRE
RISK ALSO INCREASE THE STRAP ON
OUR WILDLIFE AND REDUCE OUR
CLIMATERESILIENT. ECOLOGICALLY
SENSITIVE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM CREATED BY AB TWENTY SIX
TEN WILL PROVIDE FUNDING TO A
NUMBER OF ENTITIES INCLUDING
LAND MANAGEMENT ORGANIZATIONS
THAT PARTNER WITH CATALYTIC. TO
IMPLEMENT THESE PROJECTS ACROSS
THE STATE. TAKEN TOGETHER THESE
PROJECTS WILL REDUCE WILDFIRE
RISK OVER THE LONG TERM A LARGE
PORTION OF THE LAND AND
ECOLOGICALLY RESPONSIBLE MANNER
THIS SUPPORTS BOTH CALIFORNIA'S
FUEL REDUCTION AND BIODIVERSITY
GOALS BY LIMITING THE SPREAD OF
INVASIVE PLANTS. FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB TWENTY SIX
TEN THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU AND I
THOUGHT WE DID HAS ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT THE ROOMS ARE COMING
BACK UP. NOT A MEMBER. OUR
MEMBERS TECH HOUSTON
REPRESENTING EAST BAY REGIONAL
PARK DISTRICT VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. I'VE GOT MILE
ON BEHALF OF THE LAND TRUST OF
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE GRASSLANDS ASSOCIATION
THE ROYALS FOOTHILLS CONSERVANCY
AND SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE
EDUCATION ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION THANK YOU. ANY
S. SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE WILL TAKE BOTH AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY SIX TEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY SIX TEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
. NINE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
NEWMAN ON BEHALF. THAT OPEN
SPACE IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN THE QUEUE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY SIX TEN THANK YEAR- AND
ANY OPPOSITION HERE IN THE ROOM
OR IN THE HALLWAY. SEEING NONE
OF BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS THE COMPANY MEMBERS.
SPENT ALMOST ELECT LAST BILLS
THE FUNDING SOURCES THIS BILL TO
BE REFERRED TO APPROPRIATIONS
FOR FUNDING TO. YEAH IT IS OKAY. IF THAT SEEMS FAIR ONLY
QUESTION I HAVE A QUESTION FOR
YOU MR PRESIDENT- SO YOU HEARD
THE SUPPORT FROM THE SERIES OF
HER DISTRICT I'VE ACTUALLY HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF WATCHING THE
SHADED FUEL BREAK BEING DONE IN
MY OWN COMMUNITY ON THE WILDLAND
URBAN INTERFACE THAT DEALS WITH
INVASIVE SPECIES AND ALSO. PART
OF WHAT THEY'RE DOING WHICH I
THINK IS INCREDIBLES PLANTING
NATIVE SPECIES TO REPLACE THEM
SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO GO BACK
YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR TO
REMOVE INVASIVE SPECIES THAT ARE
CAUSING. THAT YOU'LL THAT WOULD
BE SO RISKY. OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE RIGHT THERE ON THE WILD
IN URBAN INTERFACES I THINK THIS
IS A REALLY IMPORTANT BILL AT MY
ONE QUESTION IS. THE BILL IS
FOCUSED ON CURRENT FUNDING
SOURCES. AND SO. ALTHOUGH I'VE
SEEN THAT WORK I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT.
PRIORITIZING IN A WAY THAT HARMS
THE PROTECTION OF COMMUNITIES
FROM GETTING THE WILDFIRE WORK
THEY NEED CAN YOU COMMENT ON
THAT. YEAH CERTAINLY- THAT WON'T
HAPPEN THIS JUST- WILL TRY TO
FOCUS THE WORK ON. DOING IN A
WAY THAT MAKES THE MOST SENSE
FOR THE PARTICULAR AREA- BECAUSE
LIKE YOU SAID. IF YOU DO THIS
THE WRONG WAY FOR INSTANCE IF
YOU TREAT CHAPARRAL THE SAME WAY
YOU WOULD TREAT A FORESTED AREA.
THOSE THOSE INVASIVE PLANTS JUST
COME ROARING BACK AND CREATE
MORE OF A PROBLEM DOWN THE ROAD
SO WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERY AGENCY. AND EVERY.
FIRE CREW. I'M HAS THE
SUPERVISION THAT THEY NEED AND
YOU KNOW. THAT IT'S REAL THAT
THE WORK IS TAILORED FOR THE
TYPE OF MATERIAL IN THIS IS YOU
KNOW AN ISSUE THAT WAS RAISED BY
CHAPARRAL. SOCIETY AND OTHER
FOLKS THAT THEY'VE JUST SEEN
THESE. END UP BEING
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE. SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHEN THE WORK'S
DONE IT'S WERE IT'S DONE RIGHT.
I THANK THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN
AND DO WE HAVE A MOTION. THANK
UBS ALLEY CALDERON PLEASE. THE
BURKE HAND I ERICA HAND I DOLLY
BENNETT BENNETT I BIGELOW
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA
KALRA LEVINE MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI WHEN. NO I RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS SMITH. WHO WILL
VOTE YES AND WE FOR THE FUNDING
FOR. SMITH I BE PROUD WHAT THE
PEROXIDE WARD WARD I. AND THAT
WAS OUR LAST BILL SO WE WILL
CALL THE ROLL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. OKAY THE DALLAS. THE
SERGEANTS WE PLEASE COFFEE
ADDITIONAL ABSENT MEMBERS WHO
NEED TO VOTE. THANK YOU MAYES
RUBIO FOR BEING HERE THE WHOLE
TIME. COOL START WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ABSENT MEMBERS
BIGELOW FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN I
KALRA LEVINE MERCER MURATSUCHI I
WON WHEN I SALAS WARD BY WARD I. THE ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SEVEN ABSENT
MEMBERS BENNETT. BENNETT I
BIGELOW GARCIA KALRA. SALAS WARD
WORD I. THE I DO. I TO. NOT
THINK I LEFT JUST BEFORE THE
ELECTION WOULD I HAVE YOU DOWN
AS A NO OKAY. SHE REDUCE.
RETRAIN THE VOTE EXACTLY. I
NUMBER FOUR TWENTY FIVE TWELVE
ABSENT MEMBERS BIGELOW KALRA.
SALAS SMITH CAN'T RECALL MINE ON
THAT ONE THE MILK SMITH NOW.
WARD WORD I. FOR KALRA I. THE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTY NINE. ABSENT MEMBERS
BIGELOW FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I
KALRA CHOLERA I SALAS SMITH
SMITH NO WARD WAR DIE. I ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
NINE ABSENT MEMBERS BIGELOW
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I KALRA
CHOLERA AYE LEVINE. MURATSUCHI
MERCY GI WHEN I SELES WARD WARD
I. THE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
TWENTY ONE OH NINE ABSENT
MEMBERS BIGELOW FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I. KALRA KALRA I.
LEVINE MURATSUCHI. MERCER CHANGE
NOT VOTING WHEN NOT VOTING.
RUBIO SKEWS ME SALAS. WARD WARD
I. I AM NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY FOUR ABSENT MEMBERS
BIGELOW GARCIA. KALRA KALRA I.
SALAS WARD WORD I. THE ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB. TWENTY SIX TEN.
ABSENT MEMBERS BIGELOW GARCIA
KALRA KALRA I. LEVINE. SALAS
YEAH GARCIA I. AB SOARED ONE.
CAN I HAVE THE YEAH YOU CAN'T
HAVE EVERYTHING YEAH- LET ME
CHECK. YES THANK YOU. OKAY OKAY
. THANK YOU. BUT YEAH OKAY- ONE.
WE JUST. SO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ABSENT MEMBERS KALRA. KALRA I.
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SEVEN
ITEM NUMBER THREE ABSENT MEMBERS
GARCIA GARCIA I. KALRA KALRA I.
IF YOU CAN GET FIVE DIFFERENT.
YOU KNOW THE LITTLE PANELS. BY
MARK. YEAH THANKS ASHLEY OKAY.
THE CHECK THE NUMBER OF. MISTER
IT IS NOT. IF YOU FELT. THAT YOU
KNOW WE'RE LOOKING CALL ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT. AB TWENTY THREE
FOUR GARCIA GARCIA I. I THINK
THE ONE. YEAH YEAH THE VOTE ON.
TWENTY ONE ON.
THAT I WAS READING ANALYSIS I
HAVE A LOT OF BEING SHOCKED. WE
HAVE YOUR IS NOT VOTING WAN TO
CHANGE THAT EXPERIENCE YEAH. AB
TWENTY ONE OH. MAR SUIT. NOT
GOING NOT VOTING T<c.cyan>. RIGHT. YOU</c>
CAN. OKAY SO. THIS IS A NEW LOW
COMPANY. THE GOD. YEAH WAS THE
EXACTLY YES. WE WILL HAVE- OKAY
. LASKO YEAH. W. THANK YOU. SOME
LIKE IT'S COMING BECAUSE THEY
SAID HE'S A LOT HE'S THE LAST
BILL. BEING HE THERE ARE IS
ELEVEN HOW. SCHOOLTEACHERS WELL.
YEAH RIGHT.
YEAH. I NOTHING LIKE THAT YEAH.
FIVE SYMPATHETIC LITTLE BIT WITH
THE SWING SPACE NOW I KNOW RIGHT
YEAH. HI I'M JENNA AGREE WITH
YOU FOR RIGHT. WHAT I KNOW ABOUT
THAT.
IN FACT. YEAH BECAUSE THAT WE
USUALLY GO YEAH. RIGHT OKAY OKAY
- SURE. YEAH MESSAGES. SO OKAY
YOU'RE NOT HAVING ANY.
OKAY SO YOU'RE GOING TO BE. A
FIFTY. I GOT SENT DOWN. OKAY.
RIGHT YEAH. THANK.
AND THAT'S OUR.
YEAH OKAY.
FOR THE DAY. WE HAVE TO GO
SKATING ON THERE WILL BE A GREAT. YEAH. WE'LL START WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ABSENT MEMBERS
SALAS SALAS I. WITH THE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY ONE OH
NINE ABSENT MEMBERS SALAS. SEVEN
FIVE SALAS I DO NUMBER THREE AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SEVEN.
ABSENT MEMBERS SALAS SOUTH SIDE
. I AM NUMBER FOUR AB TWENTY
FIVE TWELVE ABSENT MEMBERS SALAS
. SOUTH NOT VOTING. I AND NUMBER
FIVE AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY NINE.
ABSENT MEMBERS SALAS SALAS NOW.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY NINE ITEM
NUMBER SIX ABSENT MEMBERS SALAS
SOUTH SIDE. I'M NUMBER EIGHT AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY FOUR ABSENT
MEMBERS SALAS FALLIS FIVE. AB
TWENTY SIX TEN ITEM NUMBER NINE
ABSENT MEMBERS SALAS SALAS I.
THANK YOU MR THOUSAND THANK YOU
EVERYBODY THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED. I THINK. THAT BILLS
THAT ARE THANK YOU FOR THE.